Three,
two,
one.
Hello Tim.
How's it going?
Thanks for finally being here.
Long story,
right?
I definitely drank too much
coffee before we get here.
So if I appear,
appear like cracked out,
I swear to God I'm not in
pills but I'm glad to hear it.
But um,
so we had a nice conversation on the
phone about d platforming and social media
and um,
what,
what was very obvious to me in talking
to you was that your way more schooled on
this than I am.
So that's why I wanted to have this
conversation with you because part of what
was like,
I've really listened to my
podcast with Jack and um,
you had a good criticism of it.
I agree with a lot of what you said.
First of all,
I agree that it was kind
of boring and it was,
I think in many,
for many reasons it was my fault.
Uh,
I don't think I prepared enough for it
and I also don't think I understood the
magnitude of how other people felt about
d platforming on twitter and in all
social media,
youtube and all these different things.
And what the ramifications are and how,
how much this means to people
to have very clear and obvious,
obvious free speech outside of very
egregious examples of like threats and
doxing and things like that.
Which I think we can all agree,
right?
I think this problem might be one of the,
like one of the worst problems
we're facing right now.
Politically.
Yes.
You know that twitter is where
public discourse is happening.
It's where journalists are and this
is a problem sourcing a lot of their
stories.
Yeah.
So if you have somebody who is completely
removed from public discourse that
that's exile,
you know,
I can't,
I can imagine why some people kind of
lose their minds when that happens.
And um,
I think going into that
conversation with him,
well that's what I wanted it to be.
That's why I don't really
interview people any kind of,
have conversations with them.
Occasionally we have disagreements and we,
you know,
we talk about things and you know,
but it's not,
I don't have a,
like a mandate.
My only,
the only thing I wanted to get out of
the conversation is I wonder to find out
what it was like to start
that organization and to
have no idea when you were
doing it that it was going to be
essentially like one of the most important
distribution at a real
avenues for information and
act and act as an activist.
A buddy of mine asked me if I knew why
people smashed windows smashed starbucks.
It's not because they think
they're going to cause damage.
It's because they want to strike
a symbol down of something.
They view a process them.
Jack Dorsey is that symbol to a
lot of people and you know to see.
You know what I was saying earlier is
I think a lot of people look at you.
You're like a real dude.
You know your.
Your conversations are real.
You have.
You're not one of these
fake news journalists that
people are very critical of
that field there.
They're biased or an agenda.
So when you sit down with Jack
Dorsey and doesn't go anywhere,
people then feel like the last person
who not supposed to let us down.
Let us down,
you know what I mean?
Look,
I failed you twice as much.
I felt it and I noticed that I got
more hate for that one.
Then probably anything that
I've ever done and you know,
I'm not a guy who shies
away from criticism.
I try to figure out what I did wrong
and try to regroup and figure out how to
approach it again.
And in Jack's defense I think he's
very open to talking about anything.
And also he's also very open for self
criticism when he was openly discussing
what they're doing wrong,
where they need to be clear,
where the navy to get better.
I don't believe any of it.
I don't trust that guy.
Not at all.
Um,
you know,
why don't you trust him.
I mean,
first of all,
there's the obvious thing that is
running these a bunch of companies.
I could be wrong,
but I believe he actually left twitter.
He wasn't the CEO for a while.
They brought them back in or something,
but it either sounds like
should probably check on that.
So I try to avoid asserting things
that I'm not 100 percent sure on,
but me too.
But I do it all the time.
Anyway.
Jack says things like,
you said to you,
he said to Congress,
I believe he said he's had to Congress.
We don't ban people based on the content.
We ban people based on their conduct.
Yeah.
You literally have a terms of
service that band specific content.
Like what do you mean you don't
pay people based on content?
There's a,
you know,
I'll just get into naming some people.
Right?
Meghan Murphy for example,
as a feminine.
Megan Murphy.
Is She okay?
She's that woman that the
whole issue with women.
Right?
So,
so this is what's important.
She was responding to somebody.
Explain that.
So this could be standalone because
we talked about it yesterday with Sam
Harris,
but um,
so I don't know too much
about Meghan Murphy,
but she's a feminist.
She's a,
what they call a trans
exclusionary radical feminist.
But I think that that might be offensive.
Says let's remember why Jack
Dorsey was fired as twitter CEO.
He was fired.
Okay.
We'll see what it says.
This isn't fortune 2008.
That was.
There wasn't even.
It was sort of twitter.
Yeah.
Two thousand eight.
Jesus Christ.
I'm Dorsey's management
was so problematic.
Twitter's board,
this is an opinion piece.
Fired him in 2008 offering him a passive
chairman role and silent board seat
2010.
He was founding square,
square.
He went rogue.
Okay,
so something happened.
You know,
it's funny as you called
it an opinion piece,
but do they.
I don't know.
That's,
that's where we're at in journalism today.
Well when someone says,
well,
it has to be an opinion piece.
When someone says was so problematic.
Right.
I mean that's an opinion.
The real facts are he was fired,
you know,
you could state the specific reason
that was stated by the company and that
would be a non opinion piece,
but as soon as you flavor it,
it's all opinion,
right?
It is,
Yeah.
That is a,
that is an issue,
right?
With information,
that distribution of information.
It's flavored by opinion in ideology.
All of it.
Yeah.
Well,
we can talk about that,
but I don't want to derail anything.
Yeah.
Okay.
So Megan Murphy,
please explain it.
She was a feminist.
She said she's a.
So she's called her a trans exclusionary.
I look,
I understand this is offensive,
you know,
I guess calling someone a trans
exclusionary radical feminist,
I'm assuming that was offensive.
It's just used in a defensive way I
suppose to them to her offensive against,
against people like her.
Yeah.
So there's intersectional feminists.
They tend to be trans inclusive,
meaning that they believe that
someone who's born biological,
biological male can compete with those
bylaws biologically female if they
transition,
if they take hormones and
things like that can compete,
compete,
right?
Like power lifting,
racing bikes,
biking and stuff.
That's where I step in.
Yeah.
You know,
I've seen some stuff you've talked about,
uh,
the Trans exclusionary group think they
shouldn't and they've said things that
are considered to be part.
I say consider it to be offensive.
I'm not trying to assert
who is offended by it,
but there's one recent
story where a trans,
exclusionary,
radical feminist said that
the trans rights movement
as a men's rights movement,
right?
They say things like that.
In the case of Meghan Murphy,
she responded to someone.
She said,
men aren't women though.
That's not harassment.
Right?
That was a conversation
with somebody else.
Well,
it's also a fact she
was permanently banned.
Well,
that's crazy,
right?
That saying men aren't women.
Okay,
out of context,
just say it right there.
Men are women.
Who the fuck's gonna argue with that?
Well,
I'll let you say trans people.
Okay,
now you're into gray area,
but actually the statement,
men aren't women.
I mean,
you'd have to take it in context.
Right?
Right,
right.
But this is where we start
getting into the nitty gritty of,
I guess left wing ideologies.
The culture war.
If you go on wikipedia and you look up,
man,
it will tell you a man
is an adult human male.
Right?
But if you look up trans man,
it will say a transplant is a man and so
the transection of Wikipedia is at odds
factually with the main section.
So there was an.
I bring this up,
is that when it comes to twitter,
then we can clearly see the bias.
Twitter says you can't misgender someone
and presumably that's why Meghan Murphy
was banned.
Okay.
That's a left wing ideology.
Right?
But that's what she's talking about.
A specific human.
I think she was.
I think they were having a
conversation about somebody.
I don't know the full details details,
but I got to say,
look right now people are being banned
or suspended for saying learn to code.
Okay.
That's.
Yeah.
What is that about?
You explained that to me too,
and I saw a few people getting,
but should we start one at a time?
Should we.
Yeah,
let's stick with Megan.
Well,
I think we've,
we've,
we've reached the point of Meghan,
right?
She was banned for having a conversation
and saying men aren't women though.
That was the quote.
Men who aren't women though,
right?
So.
And they're saying that they would
never ban someone for content.
They banned them for behavior.
Right?
So if we use that behavior
that I have no idea,
like,
listen,
if you are using twitter the way twitter
was designed to engage and respond to
people is that bad conduct.
It can't be conduct.
It literally can't be conduct.
Well,
not only that,
aren't you allowed to have opinions
that are in fact based in biology?
Yes.
You should be in.
I have myself before we go any further
before you get called alt right,
you've,
you're very left,
right?
Um,
I,
you know,
I typically say center
left center look like,
Oh God.
People were saying how many
times someone commented,
how many times will tim mentioned he's
a social liberal laying on center left.
Uh,
I was a big fan of Bernie Bernie Sanders.
He's still one of my favorite politicians.
Uh,
people then call me a socialist.
You know,
conservatives call me,
left,
left calls me write whatever.
These labels are so fucking toxic.
It's so confusing to people and it.
And it causes so much,
so much division between two sides
that might not even differ that much.
You know,
the funny thing about it,
as I got my start during
occupy Wall Street and
conservatives called me far left
because I was reporting on the protests,
what they were doing,
police brutality,
the arrests.
They said this is a far
left activists now that I'm,
I've always been critical of
the more extreme factions.
Like I've got interviews from seven,
six,
seven years ago where I'm
critical of these people.
Now all of a sudden they're accusing me
of being alt right for being critical of
extremists and masks,
you know,
starting fires and things like that.
All adjacent.
That's my new favorite.
Yeah.
Boot licker out right at
Jason Wu boot Licker boot,
licker.
That's,
that's,
you know,
there's a lot of phrases that people use
that mean literally nothing boot Lifton
I'm one of one of my favorites is to
keep it in the context of twitter.
They say freedom of speech,
freedom of speech does not
mean freedom from consequence.
That literally doesn't mean anything.
It literally means nothing.
Yeah.
Well,
that's just trying to skirt
around freedom of speech.
That's what it is.
So what ends up happening,
but you agree with the like you
should be able to speak your mind,
but there's certain consequences
of certain things that you say.
If I throw this bottle at the wall,
there's a consequence.
So that's a physical move motion.
If I drink this water,
there's a consequence.
Talked about the bathroom.
Right?
So to to to point out that
actions have consequences,
not actually addressing any of the issues.
It's just literally saying nothing,
but it's,
it's,
it's almost,
it's just like a.
You can predict when someone will say it
and it's usually when a specific person
is band,
they'll say freedom of speech,
freedom of consequence,
all that stuff.
They don't say it when it's there,
people,
they say,
you know,
but,
but this is true too in talking
about twitter censorship,
there are people on the left who have
been banned unjustly and this is where it
gets actually scarier in my opinion.
You'll have,
I could name so many people,
just Jesse Kelly was banned for
no reason and CJ Pearson was bad.
I think why you say no reason why?
No,
they have no records.
That was an accident.
Oops.
They said it was an accident
plan for life or band.
He was a short amount of time.
No,
I.
So I could be wrong.
My understanding is Jesse
Kelly who was a conservative,
had his account just bent and there
was a huge stink in the media.
Like,
Whoa,
whoa.
This guy didn't do anything.
Who is Jesse killing the conservative guy,
you know,
he,
he posted snarky tweets.
He doesn't harass people or
anything is a verified twitter user.
So a bunch of stories came up saying what,
what is this twitter then
reinstates and said it was uh,
it wasn't,
it was a mistake.
Now is it possible that
they're just dealing with
blunt tools and that there was
a mistake or.
Well,
yeah,
absolutely.
Absolutely.
But then I'd have to.
The reason why I don't think it was
a mistake very simply as for one,
we can see the ideological
bent to their rules,
but then you look at someone
like Milo Yiannopoulos,
like,
I'm not a fan of Milo.
I have to make sure that
everybody knows that,
but just because I'm critical of
the actions taken against them,
it doesn't mean I support him,
but why was he banned?
Because he tweeted it.
Leslie Jones.
Right.
And the idea was that his tweet
caused his fans to attacker,
which I think is.
That's a stretch.
That's,
that's,
that's just,
that's just ridiculous.
He didn't say go get her.
He didn't say attacker.
He was tweeting at her.
Yeah.
And you know,
what did he call her?
Ugly.
Did he say something like,
since he was insulting or.
Yeah,
I think you called her ugly.
He was,
he was mocking this feminist
version of ghostbusters.
Right.
That's what he was doing.
He was talking.
It was like a critique of the movie.
Look,
I've had milo in the
podcast way back in the day.
I had them on twice.
I enjoyed talking to him.
He's hilarious.
He's very smart.
He's very witty.
He's a character.
He's very much a provocateur,
but he's also,
you know,
he's pushing buttons on purpose,
like he's trying to get
reactions from people trolling.
Yeah.
I mean,
I almost think like he
married a black guy,
just let people know he's not gay.
Let people know brother.
He's not racist.
It's hilarious in the way I.
I wouldn't,
I would never say
something like that either,
but I almost think it,
you know what I mean?
You can understand why Milo would do that.
He's calculated.
Right?
Right.
Yeah.
But he did that.
I don't think he did that.
It should be clear,
but I mean that's how much of an act.
A lot of what's going on.
But if you talk to him off camera,
he's a very nice guy.
Very reasonable,
very polite.
I don't,
I don't trust them.
I'm not,
I'm not a big fan.
You know,
he,
he fat,
shamed to do it at the gym.
Right.
Literally is a picture of my.
I'll make a photo of a guy at the gym,
the gym,
and I actually argue with them about.
At one point I was like,
you won,
you won.
You're skinny.
He's fat,
but no you can.
You literally shamed him to the point
where you decided to go to the gym to
better himself and you're
still making fun of him.
So did he would've been he shamed
him before the guy went to the gym?
No,
I mean,
I don't mean literally.
I mean like Milo's rhetoric of shaming
people and getting them saying they're
nasty and stuff and then it.
Right.
But at the guy listened to them
and that's why he went to the gym.
No,
no,
I didn't mean literally.
I just mean like if Milo plays it up,
like I'm going to shame people
until they don't work out,
why would you?
But,
but I'll say this,
look,
that's fine.
Milo can can say the nasty things and be
the kind of person is he shouldn't have
been banned from twitter.
That's ridiculous.
Why was this verification badge removed?
That was another.
It's,
it's,
it's plain as day.
The verification one was weird.
It's like we're going to keep you here,
but we're going to take away the
verification lets people know you're you.
Right.
So it opens the door to fraud.
Right?
And it opens the door to fake my lows
and you don't know who's who because
there's no blue checkmark that
doesn't necessarily make any sense.
And then we get to Julian assange
who couldn't get verified what?
Yeah,
they wouldn't have.
And so a bunch of fake
accounts started popping up.
Wait a minute.
We verified Wiki.
I believe wikileaks is but.
And then I think Julian assange his
account was changed into the defendant's
Anja count,
but it's not verified,
at least I'm pretty sure.
What was the reasoning behind
not verifying Juliana such?
I don't think there was one.
Okay.
Can we do.
Let's take a little sidebar here.
Yeah.
Can you tell me what's
wrong with Julian assange's?
Like what?
What is the idea that this guy is some,
some super villain,
some bad person that did something
terrible because the exposed some
information.
Like what am I missing?
I guess it depends on how
conspiratorial you want to get,
but joining a sign they,
they,
they've labeled him like the intelligence
agencies and I think that may have
been James Clapper,
sad that he is acting as a
private intelligence adversary
of the US or something
to that effect.
So of Russia,
you mean know that Julian assange just
acting independently against the US
against it.
Right,
right,
right.
And so that the leaks put
out very damaging to the US.
I think that's fair to say.
Sure.
They don't like them.
So,
you know,
then he ends up getting accused of,
uh,
I believe molestation.
I'm a year.
It was secrets.
So it's,
it's,
it's pretty complicated.
He was having consensual sex with a woman.
The content then?
No,
no,
I don't think so.
I think while they were in the bed,
then the accusation was
that he without a condom on,
he had sex with her again.
I don't think that's,
you know,
I'll be honest,
been years,
but I don't think that's the case.
I thought that there is a,
I'll say this,
it's been years,
I think,
you know,
but there was reference to a condom
breaking and I think what happened was he
said it was fine or something,
but,
but you know,
outside of that,
you know,
the guy has been locked up for how long,
I think,
I think it was the UN said something
like it's a violation of human rights or
whatever,
and yeah,
we went over,
it was like,
what is it,
six years if he's been locked
up for more than six years.
Yeah,
it's crazy and it's
because there's an a man.
This is getting a little
bit out of my wheelhouse,
but I think the US has preparing a
grand jury indictment against him.
So.
But again,
you know,
and Chelsea manning who gave him the
information is now free and out of jail.
I,
I don't,
I think it's presumed that Chelsea did.
I thought it was,
maybe it,
maybe it is.
It's been years since I've
tracked a lot of this stuff.
Okay.
But back to the main point,
back to the essential wasn't verified,
right?
Wiki leaks was,
I'm pretty sure.
Okay,
so verification is not just,
hey,
this is tim pool.
There's Jamie Vernon.
Oh,
that's,
that's the real Jamie.
Give him a blue check mark.
It's a we don't like you,
so we're going to take away your check
mark even though we know you're the real
you.
It's,
it's like a,
it's a class.
It's an elite class of people.
A removal of approval.
Yeah.
There are some people who I think have
removed their own verification badges.
You can just change
your name and it erases.
I think Pewdie Pie did it
once and then immediately.
Immediately.
Got It back.
Uh,
yeah,
I,
but you know why?
Why moved someone's verification?
Right?
What does that,
what does that do?
No,
I'm 100 percent agreement.
So what.
So another,
another interesting thing we can sort
of segway into is why was a Laura loomer
band?
You don't have to be
a fan of Laura loomer.
You can,
you can question her politics.
Was she a band before,
after she jumped Nancy
Pelosi's fence before,
but she's,
you know,
I'll say this man,
like I,
I tweeted about it if,
oh God talking about
twitter,
if you,
even if you don't like her,
you got to admit she
knows how to get press.
She knows how to generate that buzz
and then she's really good at it.
So what,
here's the thing,
she got banned permanently
because she tweeted to,
I believe it was Ilan,
Omar criticism about Sharia law.
She accused A.
I could,
you know,
you could pull up the tweet,
but I think she accused
Elan of promoting sharia,
which results in like all these horrific
things and they banned there for it.
Okay.
Disagree with all you want.
But that was her criticizing a politician.
You can't have a lawsuit against
John Donald trump claiming you can't,
you know,
trump can't block somebody
because it's a public forum.
But then when it comes
to a congressperson,
public just permanently banned someone
for saying something critical of their
ideology.
And I think what's really critical here
is that there has to be some sort of
clarification for what policies were
violated and how they were violated like
that.
That seems to be,
especially for public figures because
it's one thing if we don't know a person
or the background,
but when you know a person,
when there's a Laura loomer or Milo
Yiannopoulos and it's a public case,
and then you get this feeling that they
say no because we decide and this is it.
Well Joe,
don't worry because no
matter what twitter does,
they're going to be defended
by the New York digital,
you know,
journalists,
elites who will misrepresent what's
going on in an effort to obfuscate or
sometimes outright lie
about what's going on.
And this brings me to learn to code,
learn to code.
So asked you about this the other day
that people are getting banned for learn
to code.
I'm like,
what the fuck is that?
Like,
what is that?
So when coal miners were getting laid off,
a bunch of articles emerged
saying teaching minor state code,
can we teach miners how to code?
And they were showing videos about it,
I don't believe it was.
It wasn't intended to be
a derogatory or insulting,
but to a lot of people that came off
as this bourgeois let them eat cake.
Oh,
your career has been destroyed.
You're,
you're,
you're a 50 year old man with a family.
Go to Silicon Valley and do something
you've never even thought about.
Right.
Let's.
So it came off as to a lot
of people as just elitist,
right?
So when these journalists
are getting laid off,
this meme spreads,
I don't know exactly where it started,
um,
where they say,
learn to code to the journalists.
Well,
this is an interesting thing happens.
John Levine,
I think his name from the rap tweets.
Someone from twitter told me you will,
you can,
you can be banned for tweeting.
Learn to code at a laid off
journalists conservative.
Start tweeting it far and wide.
Like,
here we go.
This is a reporter from
the rap was confirmed this.
All of a sudden then other
journalists come out and say,
this is a lie.
This is not true.
This is fake news.
Conservatives are spreading fake news.
Again,
and they say,
we have a new,
a new statement from twitter that said,
we're only,
we're only banning people who are
engaging in a harassment campaign.
When I got a few problems is tweeting
a meme at somebody's critical of them a
harassment campaign?
Is that a meme it.
Yeah,
right.
It's like it condenses an idea.
So here's the thing.
I sent a bunch of screenshots,
screenshots from people.
Now people can fake screenshots.
I understand that,
but I checked some
people's twitter accounts.
I saw that they were tweeting this
and I believe for the most part,
this is what happened.
Someone tweeted something
to a buzzfeed journalists,
you know,
oh,
you guys believed x,
y,
and Z.
Yeah,
whatever.
Hashtag learned to code,
criticizing them,
suspension.
So then these,
these journalists come out and say,
this is not true.
It's just people engaging
in harassment campaigns.
So I said,
look at this guy's account.
He's got one tweet that
says learn to code.
Is that him harassing somebody?
And they said,
oh,
but you're taken out of context.
Then John Levine from the rep says,
update twitter spokesperson,
who was my source is now saying clarifying
it is about the harassment campaign,
and then another journalist
comes out and says he his quotes,
fake twitter,
deny ever saying it,
but here's the thing,
the editor and chief of the daily caller,
just a couple of,
I think couple of days ago,
took a tweet from the daily show and he,
it was,
uh,
from the state of the
Union and he tweeted,
learn to code and quote
tweeted a video suspended.
So it's very clearly not
about harassment campaign,
but why then were all of these
journalists so ready to jump up and defend
twitter when twitter.
You know what I said?
Okay.
If twitter is claiming they're banning
people who are engaging in harassment
campaign you,
you mean they've confirmed they're
banning people for tweeting,
learn to code.
They just consider it harassment.
How is it that learned
to code as harassment?
But Kathy Griffin saying to
all of our millions of fans,
I want these kids names several
times or another verified account.
I'm not gonna name because not as famous,
literally calling for the death of these
kids and instructing people to kill
them is not a bountiful offense.
It's not harassment campaigns.
That's true.
That uh,
I don't wanna I don't wanna
mention the guy's name.
I mentioned the name,
but yes,
absolutely.
He said something to the
effect of put them in a school,
lock it and burn it down.
And when you see them fire on them,
this guy is still active on twitter,
you know,
you know right now there are anti.
So now we can.
There's,
there's so much here,
dude.
Yeah,
we've got the proud boys.
All of them purged from twitter.
Okay.
Say whatever you want
about the proud boys.
If they deserve to be banned,
fine.
Why wasn't Antifa Bend?
A lot of people respond to me and say,
but Tim Antifa is random
people who were masked.
You don't know.
That's not true.
There are branded cells of Antifa that
have their own merchandise still active.
Some of these groups have published the
private information of law enforcement
officers.
Still active.
No action taken against them.
So you know,
I don't know this,
this indicates a heavy left wing bias.
I wouldn't necessarily say wing,
I would say intersectional identity.
Marion ideological bias,
right?
It's,
it's,
it's hard to pinpoint what the
tribes are in the culture war,
but twitter is clearly acting in
defense of intersectional activism.
Now,
do you think that this is a mandate?
Do you think this is written somewhere?
Do you think there's people who
are in the company that have power,
that are acting independently?
It's,
it's a grains of sand to make a heap,
right?
You're in,
you're in silicon valley,
you're in a very blue area.
The people who get hired tend to hold
certain views and because they all live in
their own bubble,
they believed the majority and thus
they think they're acting justly to band
those who are at odds with them.
And this initial engineering,
and this brings back into journalism,
the big problem,
it's,
you know,
for decades,
I don't know how long journalism has been
dominated by self identified liberals.
There's a ton of polls.
I think it was about 2015 poll showing
Republicans are like seven percent of
journalists or some ridiculously small
number and it's a really simple reason
for it.
News organizations are
headquartered in big cities.
The big ones,
you know,
seeing even Fox News is in New York,
so there's a lot of people
who work at Fox News.
We're actually liberal.
People don't seem to know
that you live in New York,
you're probably not a
staunch conservative.
So what happens then?
News breaks.
You've got all these journalists
because I've worked with them,
you know,
I worked for vice,
I worked for fusion and
they sit around at tables,
they meet up after work from different
offices and they talk about things and
they all tell each other
the exact same thing.
And so this is why you
see Covington happen.
These people will follow
each other on twitter.
So when someone tweets this Maga kid
got in the face of Nathan Phillips,
they only see each other's
tweets and they just write it.
They don't do any journalism.
And it goes it,
man,
I can't believe for days.
And that was even in the New York Times,
correct?
Yeah,
Yup.
The New York Times a Harris talked about.
It's mind blowing to me because the
second video that came out from Covington,
you literally watch Nathan Phillips
Walk into up to the kid and get his face
Bill Maher,
you know,
what?
Four or five days later it says,
the kid got in his face and I'm like,
how are you?
You know,
shame on Bill Maher for,
for,
for saying that that's not true.
But at the same time we have a series of
journalism problem and this links back
to twitter and,
and that,
that story in particular release almost
like condensed all of the problems into
one yet yet.
And what's,
what's.
What's fascinating is following the story,
an op Ed,
I believe it was in New York Times said,
stop tweeting arts.
Had never tweet Brian stelter from CNN.
Then got a statement that I always
say I believe because I don't have the
sources pulled up,
but someone from twitter said,
journalists are the
lifeblood of our platform.
And so that's why I think you've got
these predominantly New York based
progressive writers.
They're fresh out of college,
they get hired for moderate
salaries to work in a newsroom,
sit around each other all day,
sharing the same ideas,
not exploring anything
outside their bubble.
And twitter supports them because they're
the ones who drive traffic to twitter.
They keep the conversation going.
And I think that's where twitter is.
Bias partly comes from the other,
is that clearly you're in San Francisco,
you're going to have,
you know,
your,
your staff,
the people who are,
who are running content
curation and banning people.
They lean left.
So why,
why?
Uh,
Kathy Griffin wasn't banned
probably because she's,
she's very famous,
but then I have to wonder
why Alex Jones was.
So the only,
the only real differentiator there I
guess is either mainstream notoriety or
ideological tribe.
Well Jimmy,
you pulled up why Alex was been to,
which is,
you know,
it's not very clear like when,
when you think about the fact that
they were saying that he had never done
anything on their platform,
that was bantible.
And then what was the one final thing
like and Jack didn't know what he was,
he got it.
He confronted Oliver,
Darcy of CNN in DC and for several minutes
was yelling at them while they filmed
and apparently that's my understanding
was the justification for banning him
that he was harassing a journalist
or something to that effect,
which is in my opinion,
absurd.
And,
and doing it on twitter.
Um,
I guess they posted it to twitter
live on periscope with their platform.
So if you do something on periscope,
they could get you banned from twitter.
Well that's the same thing,
right?
Because they're connected.
Yeah.
I don't know at what point last.
I think it was last year,
there was like an announcement,
I saw it on twitch,
but I think it also happened on Youtube.
They like collectively said,
if you do something on our platform,
I'm sorry,
if you do something on another platform
and we see that you could lose your
status on our platform to.
Or if that means public also.
And we see that with,
with Patrion,
but I don't want to deviate
into Patriot and yeah,
we can.
We can get to that later.
But so,
so I,
in my opinion,
so it's make it makes a good point.
How does Alex Jones get banned
for giving that guy a hard time?
But Kathy Griffin doesn't get banned for
literally calling for these children.
Leading a harassment campaign
against kids names on.
Someone with millions of followers
led a harassment campaign.
I'm going to use their language,
right?
If you're calling on your
followers to do something,
you're engaging in a campaign.
But Alex Jones confronting the journalist
who advocated for his banding is a
bantible offense.
Now,
here's the important thing about Jones.
Oliver Darcy said on CNN,
it wasn't that Jones broke the rules
that got in band because you know what?
What Darcy said is he's been
breaking the rules in the past.
They never cared.
It was only because of media pressure.
They took action against him.
Okay,
well we know many other
people break the rules.
We know followup to accounts
have [inaudible] law enforcement.
We know Kathy Griffin,
lot of harassment campaign.
There's no media pressure,
that's one of the big problems.
Twitter knows conservatives aren't
going to be able to level any kind of
campaign against their platform.
There's not scared of it,
but,
you know,
I often wonder why is it that as,
as,
as prominent and powerful as
conservative groups can be,
why they often lose
these cultural battles.
And I'm not going to say
this is the primary reason,
but I will point out,
do,
does,
does twitter believe that?
Um,
you know,
I often use Sargon of Akkad as an example.
The liberalist anti saw character.
Do they believe he'll lead a group of
liberal liberalists and individualists to
twitter headquarters with
crowbars and Maldef cocktails?
Of course not.
So what did he get Ben from?
Um,
my under I with Patrion.
But what happens is original twitter
thing was that he posted an image of
interracial gay porn
at white nationalists.
So,
but I don't,
I don't.
I think that was the first time.
And then he got banned for that.
He,
he,
well,
then he came back to the
platform and then got,
um,
I don't know what
happened the second time.
I think it was banned
invasion or something,
the porn rules because sometimes I'll
be scrolling through my feed and you'll
just see porn.
I understand it.
It's not allowed.
I porns is not allowed.
I mean,
what about porn star?
It is.
I've heard it.
I've heard it is a lot
and I've heard it isn't.
It's definitely there.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
So like porn stars have porn.
If you go to a porn stars page,
you'll see porn on it.
A lot of it.
Yeah,
like real penetration.
Porn,
they don't care.
Or maybe there's truths to get marked by
someone is saying this is inappropriate
and if enough people
that follow a porn star,
I don't think it's inappropriate.
It doesn't then get flagged in the system.
Well that's good news.
I think we may have found the,
uh,
the Switzerland of the culture war porn.
Yeah.
No one wants to ban porn.
The left and the right.
They're like,
whoa,
Whoa,
whoa.
Hold on,
hold on.
It's okay.
We can bend them for their ideas.
We just leave the porn alone.
Yeah.
But,
but the point I was making,
as you see Antifa at Berkeley.
Yeah,
$100,000 worth of damage,
throwing Molotov cocktails,
threatening people in,
uh,
in Portland.
Do you had a Bernie voter
carrying an American flag?
These antifascist,
the Antifa tried stealing
the flack from them,
clubbed them over the head,
gave him a concussion,
put them in the hospital.
So when I see the ramifications of
fire from the left or the right,
what does what a conservatives do?
I mean the gop couldn't even find a
yearbook in the Virginia Governor Race.
I don't think they're considered to
be that big of a cultural threat.
They react to things,
they get upset about things
that are unfair against them,
but they don't go through the streets
with clubs and bricks and smash windows
like Antifa and other far leftists to do.
So if they do,
they're considered racist.
It's always some sort of a racist mob.
That was the,
that's like the label
they get put on them,
right?
Yeah.
And then,
you know,
like that was the label that was put
on the proud boys almost immediately,
right?
That they're white supremacists,
even though there was people of color
that were amongst the ranks and.
Well they changed the
definition of racist.
Do you know what the whole
origin of the proud boys is?
I do this kind of fucking hilarious.
Yeah.
I'm not good at Anthony Kumi.
It told the whole story on this show
because it happened with him and,
and Gavin mcinnes that Gavin mcinnes
came up with it because of a guy that
worked there and they
were doing it as a goof.
Yeah.
And then it became a movement
and then became like,
anybody can join it.
And the people that join,
they,
they took it into a radical way and then
it became looking to beat up anti fa
and it's just like,
fuck.
Well Gavin's crossed the line.
That's,
that's,
you know,
there's,
is,
and I'll point this out for your.
You mentioned media matters in a recent,
you know,
that you're talking about Alex Jones.
I wouldn't use them as
a source for anything.
Well that's a good point.
Yeah.
But it was just clips of Alex talking.
It doesn't matter.
Uh,
they,
there's,
there's a clip going around
of Gavin mcinnes where you
can hear him saying these
crazy things and you're like,
well,
he said it right,
but it turns out some of the
clubs you were talking about dogs,
they,
you know,
you really can take the context out of
things and these clips and understand
that.
So,
so what happens if I'm,
I'm,
I'm even afraid in my videos,
I don't quote people anymore
because people have taken
me reading a quote from a
newspaper and attributed to me simply
for reading someone else's quote.
And they say,
oh,
but he said it right.
I mean,
you look at the really,
Really Funny Instance of Count Dracula.
Look,
the guy with the Nazi pug
dog is a hilarious story.
And they told him context didn't matter.
So when he leaves the courtroom,
the reporter says,
you said this phrase,
which I'm not going to say,
and he says,
so did you.
If context doesn't matter,
you should be arrested too.
Yes.
But that's,
you know,
so,
so what ends up happening
is these activists groups,
they take these quotes out of context.
But,
but admittedly I think it's fair to point
out a lot of people recognize Gavin,
if you can assume there are jokes or not,
doesn't matter.
He said things that were over the,
over the line.
Well,
Gavin's the main problem,
the indefensible problem
was the call to violence,
the calling,
calling for violence.
And I don't think Gavin's like,
he's another one who's like a prankster.
He's like a punk rock style prankster.
And he likes to burn it to the ground.
Yep.
And look,
I'm a fan of Gavin's
interviews on youtube where he,
he'll,
he hoodwinked people into sitting down
and talking to them or I don't even know
if they're still up anymore.
But my,
uh,
my understanding of it
ruined some chicks life.
And I'm,
I mean this like somewhat figuratively,
she was a,
a left wing individual.
He didn't know who he was.
He asked her to come on and her friends
basically just disavowed her immediately
because she was talking to him
because she sounded an unintelligent.
Oh,
I gotta I gotta I gotTa tell you man,
he cornered her.
I don't know if you have this issue,
but for the longest time it's,
it's,
it substantially harder to
interview someone on the
ideological left than anyone
else.
Right.
So I recently reached out to,
you know,
I regularly reach out to people.
I don't,
I'm not going to name drop because
I don't want to drag people,
but a man,
it takes weeks trying to
organize a meeting with some
of these personalities who
are progressives and on the left weeks.
Yep.
Uh,
even even people who,
like I,
I've gotten messages from people saying,
yeah man,
I watch yourself all the time,
but hold on,
let me get,
let me think about it.
And talked to some people first.
I'm not saying they're doing it because
they're skittish or it's just harder.
It's a lot harder.
Well,
they're probably more cautious,
especially if you know your,
where your ideology standards ambiguous.
It's trying to figure it out.
Oh yeah.
If,
if you're,
you know,
a man,
even even David,
David Pakman engine,
be Dorky,
get dragged through the.
Sometimes I see people on twitter
calling them alternate weirdly enough or
intellectual dark web Jimmy Doors.
An interesting character.
I really liked that.
Yeah,
such an interesting guy.
He's very smart,
but he's,
he's like,
he's an angry lefty,
but like,
but he defends free speech.
He's 100 percent.
Here's,
here's my thing,
man.
I was in Berkeley,
it was this big protest against Ben
Shapiro and there's a guy wearing a mask
with a,
you know,
communist flag full,
like rent gear.
So I got to interview him and I'm like,
you mind if I interview him?
He's like,
yeah,
of course.
I was like,
really?
Oh,
that's surprising.
And then we start talking and I said,
how do you feel about these people
that dress in all black and you know,
are,
are fighting people and causing problems.
Oh,
that's terrible.
And I was like,
you think so really?
It's actually,
I'm surprised because often when I see
people wearing fully masked up with
communist stuff,
they're typically in favor of the,
uh,
by any means by any means
necessary strategies.
And he was like,
no way,
man,
that's wrong.
And so I'm like,
you know what,
man,
I don't care if you're communist,
I don't care if you're whatever,
as long as not an authoritarian who
thinks you have the right to beat other
people to instill your ideology on them
or use manipulative force or coercion or
extortion like.
So let me,
let me,
let me talk about why I think what we're
seeing with twitter might be one of the
biggest problems ever.
Twitter,
Youtube,
facebook.
These platforms are
where we exist socially.
Politically.
It's where our ideas are exchanged.
It's where we learn about who we are
going to vote for or why we won't vote for
somebody.
When you band somebody,
you exile them,
they're no longer part
of that conversation.
So they're very much so told
you are outside the city walls,
right?
You can't come in,
you can't talk to us and there's
nothing you can do about it.
But then when you realize
the rules are actually bent,
you know,
they're slanted in a certain direction,
you can then predict
where things are going.
Did you see the green,
the green,
new deal?
Alexandria sizer Cortez?
No,
there's.
In so she publishes,
it's a nonbinding resolution,
which means that even if it passes,
they can't enforce anything,
but my God,
I have the fact sheet.
They released alongside it,
literally said they want to provide
economic security for people who are
unwilling to work.
Right.
What?
Unwilling.
Okay.
I swear to God.
Yeah.
CNBC reported this.
They cover this.
Apparently this got removed from the site.
The reason I bring this up is
there's a chart from the echo,
the economist.
I frequently show this in the content I
make where you can see the Conservatives
are coalescing around a common ideologies.
For Awhile there was an upset in the
party because people didn't like trump,
but now they've pretty much,
you know,
they say it's the party of trump.
People agree with them.
Ted Cruz even stands and
gives him a standing ovation
at the state of the union,
but the left has been spreading out.
And again,
this is from a chart put
together by the economist.
The Democrats are very clearly being
spread from far left to center and it's
kind of making it very
difficult for the Democrats to,
you know,
put forth something that makes sense.
If Alexandria Cortez,
you know,
she puts out the green new deal,
but in the bill it talks about equity,
racial justice,
the gender pay gap,
things that have nothing
to do with the environment.
And then Nancy Pelosi
says it's green dreams,
you know,
and she,
and she derides this.
You can see that there's a new
faction of the Democrats that have,
you know,
holy ideological drive.
And I think one of the reasons for
this is what we see on social media,
right?
The,
the ideological bent of the platforms
then lead to the mass followings of
specific individuals who then use
specific tactics to get elected.
And it's,
you know,
when,
when these platforms only
allow certain ideas to form,
those ideas will naturally rise
to the top of our political space.
And then you get crazy stuff.
Like if you're unwilling to work,
we'll provide you economic security,
which,
you know,
I don't know necessarily what that means
other than some people who choose not
to work.
We'll get paid,
I guess from taxpayer money,
but that seems completely insane.
And not only that,
where's that money coming from from you?
This is actually what,
another funny thing that.
No,
I mean,
let him know what you mean.
Literally.
Yeah.
Andrew is Andrew Cuomo.
Sad,
God forbid if they're rich,
leave New York because,
uh,
I believe one percent of New York,
the top one percent pay
46 percent of their,
of their taxes,
of the revenue they use.
And so they just had a
big budget shortfall,
I believe it was something trump did
that caused a shortfall in there.
And they were asked if
they would tax the rich.
And he was like,
no,
God forbid,
you know,
they'll leave and they're already leaving.
So I'm,
you know,
incoming incoming,
a million people saying I'm
conservative for bringing that up.
But you know,
facts are facts I suppose.
Well,
facts are facts and that's what's really
important about this and that when you
suppress any,
any ideology,
if you are on the left and
you suppress the right,
it is just going to shore up their
defenses and they're just going to harden
their line.
That's just how it goes.
That's how human nature is.
You can't tell people what to do.
You can't.
You're right.
And you know,
a lot of people might say,
I'm a little alarmist when I
mentioned a potential civil war,
but let me clarify like I don't.
I'm not saying because I've
brought this up before,
I'm not saying it's going to be like
18 hundreds to big battlefields,
but at the same time,
what people don't seem to realize when
it comes to history is that when you read
about World War II,
we've condensed all the highlights into
a very short paragraph or a series of
paragraphs and you don't realize
the war was several years.
There were periods where nothing happened,
right?
I was in Egypt during
the second revolution.
You could look down and you could
see Tahrir Square people screaming,
laser pointers,
helicopters,
Apaches,
and they announced on the news,
we just,
we've deposed the
president two blocks away.
A dude's eating a
cheeseburger at Mcdonald's,
watching a football match
as if nothing's happening.
So when you look at these street battles,
the political violence,
when you look at the,
the,
the biased banning's,
you look at the dude,
there was a guy who fired a couple of
rounds at a police officer in Eugene,
Oregon,
and some bombs got planted at the police
department or somebody planted bombs at
a statue in Houston.
It starts to feel like there's some kind
of political violence that is bubbling
up that can't be mended at this point
when a lot of this comes from the
suppression that we're talking about
where people don't feel like they have a
voice or that voice is being
suppressed by an opposing ideologies.
You know?
Yes.
But it is really complicated and it's,
it's I,
I can't claim to know
how everything happens,
but what I will say is I believe social
media is responsible for the political
violence.
I believe it's a,
it's not just about suppression,
it's you look at the systems
that were built facebook,
right?
What content can make it to the
front page of your facebook posts,
your facebook profile when you're
looking at your newsfeed while twitter,
facebook has to build an algorithm
to determine what matters.
Most companies then figure out how to
manipulate that algorithm to get that
content in front of you.
Because you know at most you can
see what three posts on facebook.
So what happens is early on,
companies quickly found out that anger
drives the most shares on any emotion.
All of a sudden we see a wave
of police brutality videos.
There was one website that posted almost
exclusively police brutality content
and it was like Alexa,
400 in the world,
some ridiculously high
number of blew my mind.
I knew,
uh,
someone claims that they're making six
figures writing police brutality articles
because it was pure rage bait,
right?
Content that just shares really easily.
But that content constantly being put
in front of somebody breeds an ideology.
You then tell someone,
did you know that?
You know,
white supremacy is on the rise and there
are 11 million white supremacists in
the US and they go,
I can believe it,
but that's nonsense.
It's just not,
it's just not the case.
You know,
the Anti Defamation League and the SPLC
say that at rough estimates or maybe
like 10 or 12,000,
but people really believe that there is
like at the president does secretly a
Nazi and that he's being propped up
by the secret cabal or there's an
alternative influence network on Youtube
where you and me or somehow trying to
convince people to,
you know,
this is ridiculous.
So that's the,
the main thing.
Yeah.
What was it called?
Data and society.
And that's,
that's that nonsense.
Yeah,
we did.
We did.
We get connected to,
are we outright adjacent
or we boot licker that one.
We're part of the network that feeds
into extremist ideologies and other.
They connected me with
people with schizophrenia.
The way it's drawn out,
the little map where one person's
connected to another person.
And what I said to her,
I said,
Barbara Walters interviewed Fidel Castro.
Did that make her a communist?
You know,
that's what I tweeted at her.
I'm like,
you're crazy.
This is a crazy way to look at things.
But what happened with that story?
Media reported uncritically.
I reached out to a bunch of journalists.
I know a ton of journalists.
I'm a,
I'm a member of the
online news association.
You're like,
I've been a speaker at their events
and I'm reaching out to the journalists
like,
hey,
why did you guys write that?
That's just completely fake.
It's got my name,
like my name in the middle,
you know me,
you can call me to quote you.
They don't do it right.
They just uncritically reported and
there's a couple reasons for it.
The media,
uh,
facebook recently changed their algorithm.
I don't know,
this was a while ago.
They may have changed it again,
but it was a huge hit to the incomes of
a lot of these companies when all of a
sudden news articles stopped appearing
as much because facebook wanted friends
and family to be more connected
and less so news organizations.
So these news organizations who write
this viral clickbait and rage content
weren't getting as much traffic.
So what are they,
you know,
they have to go crazy.
They have to,
you know,
and so it's,
it's,
it's a downward spiral of where these
journalists all follow each other.
They start producing.
I don't,
I don't think it's a conspiracy.
They produce this stuff.
I think they're hired specifically because
the content they produce is viral and
it's viral for a reason.
Right.
And so the more they produce it,
the more they eat their own,
you know,
excrement essentially.
And then it's a game of telephone where
they're sitting in a circle constantly
telling each other the craziest things
and it gets crazier and crazier.
But another aspect of it is when
they write an article saying,
you know,
trump is racist,
it goes viral.
The next day they can't
read the same article.
So they write,
trump is the most racist.
The next day they have to
get to keep one upping it.
And it gets.
We talked about this with Forbes articles,
the term nasty surprise.
They use it with tech,
like they'll say the new galaxy
s 10 has a nasty surprise.
The new iphone 10 has a nasty surprise.
And keep saying has it,
it's hilarious.
It's almost like there's a form letter
and they just take whatever x box,
stick it in their nasty surprise and it's,
it's 100 percent clickbait and it's
Forbes and you telling me that Forbes,
that was essentially a user contributions.
Yeah,
I could probably submit an article.
They have like a network of people
don't know how you get approved,
but there's a lot of articles that get
written about like the new video game
today.
So it's like a clickbait
title can just get some ads,
has a nasty surprise,
but it's almost like they have like a
pattern that they've just accepted that
it's going to work.
But it's not a conspiracy.
It's just like minded people who
are only ever around each other,
sharing the same things among each other,
believing all the same things.
And so you'll notice that certain words
emerge specifically amongst certain
groups,
you know,
like the left will use certain words
and then if like learn to code.
It doesn't appear that
much in left wing rhetoric.
But the Conservatives and the anti
identitarian types understand what it is.
And so the justification for
banning someone for saying
learn to code regardless
of the context seems insane.
Yeah.
That seems.
It seems like you got one in
particular is almost independent.
I mean,
not almost.
That's indefensible.
Absolutely.
Like there have been people who,
uh,
let,
let me,
let me be fair.
There are people on the
left who have been banned.
Absolutely.
There was a lot of Venezuelan accounts
that were banned and a lot of people were
very critical.
I saw Abby Martin was,
was criticizing this because they
accused them of being government actors
because they were pro
Venezuelan government.
But the most,
the one thing,
there's some occupy Wall Street
activists who absolutely detested me.
They lie about me.
I do not like them for doing this.
They were banned abruptly
for literally no reason.
And this is what's more worrisome
to me is that no one defended them.
No one defended them because
conservative certainly won't,
but neither will the mainstream,
you know,
ideological left.
These are activists for class issues,
for international issues
there on the left squarely.
And they were accused guess
of being bots or something.
Just it was just an abrupt purge of like
50 accounts and some of them were like
independent citizen journalists
just wiped out and with no recourse,
no recourse whatsoever.
So I mean at some point you have to
realize how important twitter is when the
president is on it.
Could you imagine if there was a physical
space where everyone was talking and
the president shows up and everyone
keeps yelling at them and they're all
talking because you had that lawsuit
where they said it was a public forum.
Imagine that happens and then a private
private individual bars you from hearing
what the president has to say.
Right?
It's a complicated issue.
You know,
you get a lot of people on the left
saying private businesses can do whatever
they want.
That blew my mind because the left
was usually about not letting massive
multinational,
billion dollar corporations get
away with suppressing speech,
but
it was another thing that people get
pissed at me about Jack Dorsey and rightly
so that he said that it's a human right
that the Medicaid online as a human,
but the fact that he said it,
but yet all these people were banned.
So how was like to take
away someone's human right?
There should be an egregious example.
I mean it should be something like doxing,
someone like calling for violence,
like trying and buddy buddy,
but even then,
but clearly that's not the case
if Kathy Griffin still online,
but hold on,
you can kill a human
being and get 25 years.
Right.
Good point.
So you can literally
strip someone of their,
of their.
Yes.
Everything and still not
be purged permanently.
This was one of the things that
Jack and I discussed post podcast.
I said,
you know,
when we were going back and
forth about doing this again,
you know,
I told him I would really like to
see if there's some sort of a path to
redemption,
like uh,
you know,
for example,
for Milo,
I mean,
who's to say like we talked
about yesterday about
Christian ecoline who was a
white supremacist who realized the
error of his ways and then became this
activist against racism and now he
gives these ted speeches and he's,
you know,
wha accepted by everyone as being this
guy who's achieved redemption and really
understands the error of his ways.
If Milo was banned for life,
Milo is only like 34 years old.
Right.
How old is Milo around there?
I honestly don't know.
I,
I hope,
I hope I didn't make them older
than he is and probably be mad,
but whatever it is,
like who's to say that Milo,
you know,
in three years from now won't have
a change of heart or you know,
have a fucking acid trip or something.
That makes sense.
I'm a different person.
But if you're banned for life,
we are.
We throwing people away like you
ever see that tweet from like,
I'm going to say,
I think it was tyler,
the creator where he said,
how is cyber bullying real?
Just,
you know,
like close your eyes.
Go inside,
close your eyes.
That's,
you know.
I'm sorry man.
You want a band?
Hate speech.
I can understand.
I am no fan of hate speech.
I think it's wrong.
I think you shouldn't target people for,
for a specific characteristics.
We should respect one another.
At the same time.
I'm also a human adult who
understands sometimes people are mean.
You ever walked out?
You ever go to a subway in Los Angeles
and some guy starts calling you all the
names in the book.
What are you gonna do about it?
Nothing.
That's just life.
People are mean sometimes
if they punched you,
that crossed the line.
But on twitter,
you know,
Milo wants say mean things block mute.
You know what I'd do?
I press.
Yeah,
mute black people.
I blocked some people.
You had the Milo.
One was very,
very weird.
They were looking for.
And here's the other part of it,
you know what he ultimately got in trouble
air quotes for was him talking about
the positive experiences that he
had as a young man being molested.
I think that was after he
was already band though.
I don't think so.
Well,
he might've been banned
from twitter already,
but then he got kicked off
of Youtube and he left.
I don't think he stayed off youtube.
He's,
I think he's still on Youtube.
Was it,
was it Breitbart that he left fired?
He quit Breitbart,
Breitbart.
It's another thing too though.
Uh,
you know,
I see all these journalists writing
all these articles saying like,
Milo has gone,
Milo is whining and he's no more.
I'm like,
Dude's got like 6 million followers
across his instagram is youtube and his
facebook,
he posts all the time you have.
He's not in the public conversation
as much as he was before because
Dave censored him when
you're not on twitter.
Right?
The journalists who make up a huge core
of their verified users who apparently
according to CNN and a car,
like the lifeblood,
their platform on top.
I'm talking about you.
But here's my point,
he's not saying that men should
go have sex with younger boys.
He was basically saying that it could
be a positive experience because it was
for him.
Well,
I don't,
I don't know anything about what
happened in that capacity in my.
My point was if I said when I was 13,
a 21 year old girl fondled me,
do you think I'd get in trouble
if I said it was awesome?
No better wouldn't.
You wouldn't know.
Yeah,
that's right.
My brother was pointing out because a law
and order Svu is basically on 24 slash
seven.
It's like 98 percent of the
episodes are only ever about women.
Never about men being victims.
Sometimes they are.
But he was like,
oh,
I just realized that.
And I was like,
let's decide.
Well that's special victims unit.
That's the show.
I mean the,
the,
they have so many
versions of law and order.
But that one in particular,
I don't know.
But I mean it deals with sex crimes.
Yes.
And almost every episode rarely
ever talks about male victims,
which exists.
You know what I mean?
And so I,
I don't want to get like
into a men's rights thing,
but no,
I think it's fairly
obvious to a lot of people.
Like you mentioned,
if you said it,
nobody would have cared but Milo's gay.
Right.
And so that becomes,
you know,
becomes a thing for him.
Yes.
Yeah,
yeah.
It's um,
there's,
we need some kind of clear guidelines,
right,
where you can operate inside
these guidelines and also fair.
It's just,
I mean,
to an extent,
to an extent that it is tough shit.
Comedians will be allowed to
operate dancing on the line,
you know what I mean?
Like obviously I think so I'll tell you,
I can't tell you this shit.
I'll tell you something
after this is over,
you're going to think it's hilarious and
we'll find out about it in the future.
Oh,
not everyone's going to be secret.
No,
no,
no.
It's not a secret.
It's a comedy secret.
It's,
it's about something.
But,
you know,
but I'll take this call you to remind me,
but I'll take this opportunity to segue
into another point when it comes to the
bias,
right?
How is it that you can have Jimmy Kimmel,
Jimmy Fallon dress in black face on there?
Glen a CNN made a big list.
I don't know exactly when it happened.
I think a kimball was on the man show.
He dressed like a basketball player.
Oh Jeez.
And Jimmy Fallon.
Just like Chris Rock.
Oh,
Jesus.
Sarah Silverman did it.
She.
I think she addressed it though.
Yes.
Everybody.
Nobody loses their minds.
Nobody loses their minds over
that because they're on the left,
you think?
I Dunno.
It's,
it's,
I,
I honestly,
I would say to an extent,
there's probably some kind of tribal bias.
Well,
I think when you're going back to high
school yearbooks looking for outrage from
55 year old people,
if you've lost the plot,
isn't that.
Isn't that crazy?
It's fucking insane.
Well,
what's.
What's crazier is when Kathy Griffin
tweets out that the three points are hand
sign at a Covington basketball
game was a Nazi hand gesture.
Like the three point.
Oh,
to three point seven as this thing.
Yup.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm not going to do it because
the photos a little slow.
Okay.
People send it,
definitely put a series of them on my
instagram when I found out I put bill
cosby doing it.
Someone found one of me from news radio.
Isn't it?
Aren't they using it though,
for that symbol?
I know that it's a,
it's a universal symbol.
That means a lot of things,
but using it as that symbol,
they're not using it to
mean white power and.
No,
they're not.
What are the one that said it's not?
Okay.
Well,
what were those cops using it for?
That's the,
that's the,
that's the uh,
the,
what is it called?
It's called the okay.
Game of the don't look game where you
put the symbol under your waist and if
someone looks at you get to punch him.
What is a game?
Kids play?
No,
no,
no.
The Swat cops that had it on their,
on their legs?
No,
there were all doing it.
There was like four of them doing it
in a photograph and then holding it up.
Or are they holding on their legs?
I don't know.
No,
but let's,
let's,
let's break this down.
I can explain this to you.
Okay.
Please do.
Donald trump,
when he talks,
he makes the okay sign.
He's pointing.
He's making.
I mean,
okay,
well if he does it this way,
is that okay?
Oh No,
I don't.
He does this.
No,
I don't care what trump
does the flip people off.
It's probably a bad thing,
but.
So what happens is he starts doing the.
Okay.
10 they'll.
Sign.
So a bunch of trump
supporters start doing it too,
to be like,
Hey,
I'm like trump.
Right?
A four Chan campaign gets started saying,
convince everyone.
This actually means white power,
right?
It was fake.
The Anti Defamation
League said it was fake.
Yes.
A bunch of journalists said it was real.
That's what I put on my instagram.
Put all this on my instagram,
including the article where would show
the original thing came fortunate.
Fortunate.
It's fucking hilarious.
Powerful.
It's Whoa.
It's hilarious how much shit they start.
They started the flat earth movement.
Okay.
There's the guy was that?
I'd never heard that.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
They started to look at this photo and
see if I could give you a little bit.
It popped up to conspiracy.
How do we get it back?
It's that what's going on?
The connection to the TV's just died out.
I have no idea.
No Hollywood conspiracy.
The button that I have is making it
go there and it's not going there,
so I don't know.
Jesus.
Jamie.
This gremlins in this
fucking will figure it out.
It's hard to.
Allegedly.
I would say this.
We need to see that though.
My laptop.
Yeah.
Show.
Show me a laptop.
I would.
I would be willing to.
Okay.
There's the image.
Take a good look at it,
tim.
So okay.
These guys,
they see what's on their leg.
Yes.
That's specifically a game
where when you look at it,
they get to punch you,
that they're not holding the hand sign up.
They're not flashing it like
you see conservatives do.
Right.
I'm not denying that is a game,
but to say that that's what those
guys are doing is a bit of a stretch,
I believe.
Well,
what do you think they're doing?
What does it have to say that if,
if fortune did that to make to mix it
up at some point people would think that
that is true though.
That's like no way that's happening.
Look,
I'll say this is.
It is.
Well,
there's be bleeding free.
Bleeding came from fortune,
right?
Have you don't know what French
people explain that to people.
It's all you free bleeding was fortunate.
Thought it would be hilarious.
By the way,
Shiela Bu was at the
comedy store last night.
I wonder why because we're
always ragging on him.
Free bleeding came from
four chan where they said
that they were promoting this idea that
for women's rights that they would,
you know,
get away,
get away from this whole idea of you
have to control your menstrual cycle.
You know,
it's empowering to just
bleed all over your crotch.
And so women actually started
doing it because it actually,
if you can fucking,
if you can get those ideas out there,
a certain number of knuckleheads are
going to take it and run with it and think
it's real.
Of course you don't think that's possible.
The white power though,
I think it's extremely unlikely.
I think it's.
It's possible.
So here's the thing,
nothing's absolute right.
Are there some some white supremacists
who are doing it for sure,
but you don't.
You think you looking at
bad asses with fucking guns.
They're playing this little
silly game to really.
I think there are a bunch of bros.
Who are you ever.
You ever hang out With?
Like some frat dudes at a college,
they punch each other.
That's there's a game.
So how's it go again?
you,
you make the okay hand sign.
Okay.
And you hold it under a
table or on on your leg.
These are adults.
These are guys that are not in college.
They're definitely not
a below 25 years old,
but what does that mean?
I know I know 40 year old guys
who play pokemon go is a game.
You fix this fucking thing.
Well
okay,
but what the gender,
what is their job?
What would they.
Their swat team guys is that they were
arresting a drug dealer and what do,
what do you think they're doing?
They're trying to make sure everybody
knows that they're flashing and overt
white power hand gesture because
everyone knows that's what it means.
That somebody didn't think everyone knew.
Well,
no,
that's just not.
It's just not the case.
The thing that the point is holding the.
Okay sign up next to you is what's key.
You know,
people say it,
it's the w in the peat.
Putting it on your leg has always
been the punch him game or whatever.
Like I know that punch them,
punch them game 100 percent,
put it the okay symbol on your
leg or under a table and you say,
hey look.
And if they look on and see it,
they go,
ah,
and then you punched him in the arm.
But I know it so well that I,
that's why I don't think that's what
they're doing like me and my friends play
it.
So then the question is,
yeah,
so it's a major.
It's made you look made,
you look right.
So,
but what are they doing right?
Look,
look,
listen,
man.
If you wanna,
if you want to make assumptions about
what you think their intentions were,
that's all.
You don't have any facts to support that
and the only thing I know of is there
that game where you put the okay sign
in your leg and then you punch somebody
and here's some guys putting
the case on their leg.
What evidence do we have?
It's anything other than that,
nothing.
So that that's.
I'm not gonna go any Further than that.
I'm going to say,
was it poor judgment?
Oh,
hell yeah.
Maybe.
But listen,
do you know about what happened in philly
with these marines who got beat up by
antifa?
No,
I do not.
So there's some.
So there was a rally put on by
some constitutional libertarian.
I don't know exactly
what it was all about.
Antifa shows up in protests.
Some marines apparently are just walking
by because there was a marine event.
Antifa sees them and yells,
are you proud?
they said,
he says,
I'm a marine,
and said,
are you a proud boy?
And he said,
you know,
I don't know.
They'd beat them up.
These they arrested,
several people charged
with multiple felonies.
Marines got beat up.
They didn't know it.
Proud boy was.
So to assume that these guys know
anything about what's going on in,
in
cultural politics,
it's,
you know,
when you're in the know and you're on
twitter when you're reading the news all
day,
you look at the insight,
they knew what they were doing,
what these are small like what city of
these guys from even do they watch the
news all day?
Do they go on four chan,
do they go on vox.com and read
and know what this is about.
Okay.
I appreciaTe your looking at
this with a broad perspective,
but it is entirely possible that they did.
Sure.
It's also entirely possible that within
their friend group it means you're
buying lunch.
It could mean a million things.
It could mean in the cultural
context of 2018 when this happened.
Yep.
That.
Oh the okay symbol doesn't
even mean white power.
It iS,
it is.
It is a tribal sign among anti identify,
anti intersectional and trump supporters.
But don't you remember when was there?
There was a woman that
got in trouble for it.
She was in court and
she had it on her arm.
She was just standing
there like so insane.
So insane because she was basically,
she had her finger and
her thumb like that.
And they and they and
they went wild with it.
Yeah.
She's making powers.
You have to understand when I see
that and I see that you kicked me out,
but there's a difference between someone
just moving their hands around and
doing this and you know,
making a weird thing she did.
She did fall onto it the next day though.
Probably on purpose.
Maybe.
Maybe that's what she does
when she puts her on there.
You have to assume
she's watching the news,
then I would.
She's sitting in the cabinet hearing,
but it's entirely possible that I'll be
an unlikely that she was just telling
somebody.
Okay.
Like she was.
She's used to doing that with her arm.
I think about it.
There's,
you're allowed to make assumptions.
Right?
And operate off assumptions.
But eventuallY you start getting off so
crazy and you know how many assumptions
are going to believe until
you believe in the moon.
Landing was fake.
Let me ask you this though.
Don't you think that some people do that
and they do it because they're making
the symbol for white power?
Some as in what?
10,
15,
20?
I don't know.
I think I don't know about.
Like I said,
listen,
nothing's absolute.
I'd be.
I'm pretty sure they're probably
some white supremacists who do that.
Yeah,
but here's the thing.
Most of these people who are on four,
chan,
who would even use the emoji
who would do it in public,
they're not doing it
to signal white power.
They're doing it as signal opposition
to the tribal left when they take photos
and you see someone like kasandra
fairbank's who is a trump supporting,
you know writer.
She has.
She,
she is.
She is notable because
she stood at the podium,
made the okay hanson and then
this writer from splinter news,
which used to be called fusion.
I worked there,
full disclosure,
claimed it was a white power hand gesture
and she got a cassandra sued over it.
She ultimately lOst because it's
like free slander is hard to sue for,
but she did it because
it was a trump sign,
not because it's white power.
So the people who were even
white supremacists aren't
signifying white power.
They're signAling to other
trump supporters too,
right?
It doesn't mean white power.
Right?
So just because someone on the
left says it means white power.
That does not mean it means
why power within their group.
Is that what you're saying?
Yeah,
we all just decide that
this means something else.
Like
my friend means peace among peers,
among nations,
peace among worlds.
My friend steve rinella.
We talked about this in the pockets that
he got beat up once by his friend where
he grew up in Michigan and in
Michigan as almost like for fun.
Like,
like if I said,
hey fucker,
like if I called you,
like as friends you would laugh and like,
what's up dude?
You know,
it'd be cool.
So he would give the bird and
they would call it the Michigan.
Hello?
Yup.
And so the Michigan wave
or something like that.
So as he was driving by,
saw his friend,
he went like that,
like if I saw you do that,
I'd be like,
ah,
what's up tim?
There was a,
but you don't have to submit.
His friend didn't know this.
So his friend,
he grabbed him through to the ground.
He goes,
you want to fight motherfuckers like,
what are you talking about?
Like what's going on?
He's like,
you gave me the bird.
oh jesus,
I'm from Michigan.
Like That's,
we're having fun.
Like that's just,
I'm your friend.
and he was over the guy's house helping
them build a greenhouse or something.
Like he was doing some work with the
guy and the guy's still threw him to the
ground because he thought that this was a.
You goT it fixed.
No,
there's naturally,
there's going to be a ton of people,
you know,
saying,
oh,
tombs boot licker and all that
stuff on premises through men.
Like I'm not,
I,
I do not.
I'm not a big fan of conspiracy theories.
I'm not a big fan of making assumptions
about the intentions of other people.
If you can prove it,
I'm willing to hear it,
but people in this country are
innocent until proven guilty.
What do we have?
We have a photo of some
cops doing something dumb.
Do I think it was ill advised
it was wrong and should've done.
of course absolution have done it.
Do I think it means
they're west palm assists?
No,
the cops.
I'm not going to look.
I've,
I,
I am no fan of police.
you know,
I,
I grew up as like a,
a left far left.
EnTer skateboarder.
A cop screw with me all the time.
I've had cops kicked my door in.
Guns drawn.
I was in chicago and cops pulled me over.
Me and my buddies.
This is all on video at gunpoint.
Screaming at us.
It was the craziest
experience I've ever had.
I am no fan,
but if you don't have evidence,
I'm not just going to say
this is a thing about how,
how these biases function.
You get people who will
see all these videos,
a lot of these experiences and they
immediately assume the worst about these
guys.
I don't know anything about these guys.
I know they did something dumb,
but I don't know why.
So I can't really go beyond that other
than I believe their official statement
was there playing the game,
but I could be wrong but to,
to make assumptions about their character
or what they believe simply because
they made an okay sign on their leg.
It's like you can't convict
somebody in a court.
You know what I mean?
And I'm,
I'm a big fan of the presumption of
innocence and blackstone's formulation and
how we side on the,
uh,
we,
we err on the side of
protecting the innocent.
I think you got a good point in also in
the fact that this is a extremely recent
hand gesture that's being associated with
white supremacy and clearly came from
and you have to assume these guys
are on four chan or read these,
these websites like,
c'mon man,
these dudes,
they probably go to work all day.
They talk about football,
they go home,
they sit in their lounge chair and have
a beer and a slice of pizza or whatever
it is they do.
I don't think these guys,
people,
man,
you know,
people don't know how to separate
their own personal bubble from reality.
They assume,
if I know what you must know it,
right?
It's actually something
shane smith told me.
He said,
he doesn't understand.
Why is it that if he can do it,
you can't write,
and that's an interesting point
that people don't seem to realize.
Do you mean by that?
LIke he's,
he's had to meet.
I can speak french.
Why can't you like people live in this
mindset where they assume If I know it,
everyone knows it rides so,
so they're going to be like,
no,
every.
I saw an article about that.
Everyone must know what it is.
It's like,
no,
dude.
There are some people who don't watch tv.
There's some people play
video games all day.
There are some people who
don't do any of that for all,
you know,
these guys,
they everyday after work,
they go to a children's shelter and
provide soup and they don't watch the news
at all.
Like,
I'm not,
I don't believe that they actually do.
I'm just saying you have no idea
what's going on in their lives.
you're making assumptions about
what they know who they are.
And I think,
you know,
I,
I'm a firm believer that we have
problems of racism in this country.
I believe a institutional systemic racism,
real,
real problems need to be solved.
All that stuff that still doesn't mean
you get to just label someone and make
assumptions about what they believe,
who they are because of one thing,
you know,
if,
if you'd made a,
if you made a joke,
what if,
what if they did it because they
were ironically doing it right?
If you made a job 10 years ago,
am I going assume you
actually believed that?
Maybe said something silly.
You know,
we had this newscaster in New York who,
who accidentally said martin luther,
you know,
uh,
and I,
and again,
you know,
another one.
Yeah,
absolutely.
And you also,
uh,
and another thing happened that no one
cared about was a guy on cnn said a
racial slur for jewish
people in the same way.
No one cared about that one,
you know.
So there was a cnn anchor.
What did he say?
I don't want to say it.
Okay.
But he was,
he was,
he's k word,
right?
I think you can still say it
as long as I'm not calling me.
It was the same thing.
He quickly fit,
corrected himself and that
didn't come up as an issue.
But the point is this,
dude,
you know,
why?
Why is he being fired?
Right.
Even people came to his defense,
are you going to assume
nasty things about them?
Like,
are we really getting to the point
where we're gonna look at a photo.
We don't know the context.
We don't know who these people are wanting
to know their names and we're going
to be a light burned at the stake.
Well,
there's another issue too,
and this is what we're doing it.
Oh jesus.
That's so crazy.
I didn't even.
I meant to do this,
but there is another issue that people
do accidentally like because they're
worried about saying something.
They will say something.
Right.
I had a friend and he was a warmup,
a guy for a television show.
Do you know how a warmup works?
Like there's a save a
sitcoms being filmed.
There was a guy who will
keep the crowd laughing.
Yeah.
He walks around to keep the crown
and he had an anxiety attack.
He had a panic attack in
the panic attack was this.
He was doing the cosby show and he was,
for whatever reason,
it got into his head.
Don't say the n Word,
don't say it,
don't say it.
And he started sweating and he said
he started stammering and he literally
couldn't talk.
He had some anxiety issues and and
he locked up and literally couldn't.
Could barely say it.
Did he?
No,
he didn't say it,
but he was terrified that
he was going to say it's,
but that could be what's going on with
someone saying martin luther coon,
like especially the second guy,
obviously with context.
Obviously the second guy heard the first
guy do it and it was a freudian slip.
It's in his mind.
Don't say it.
Whatever you do,
don't say that.
I'll let you in on a funny,
funny little secret though.
Ice.
I did it in one of my videos.
You said that and then I started laughing.
It was about,
it was about it.
It was about the guy.
It was about the story and so you said
it and I said it laughed and I just
decided that I had at my videos,
you know,
I don't do it.
I don't do live shots,
you know,
I do a lot sometimes,
but I was just like,
I was,
I started laughing.
I just literally just started
laughing and I'm like,
I can't believe it because the
story was about him saying it.
I purposefully don't say these words on
youtube because I don't want to get the
banhammer sure.
So I'm like,
this guy accidentally said martin luther
and then he used a slur and then later
when I was reading it,
I said it and I started laughing.
I'm just like,
but I,
I understand what it's not
even about saying this.
Alerts about when you have two words in
your head and you accidentally put them
together.
Yes.
You know,
that's what happened.
The cnn guy.
Well sometimes I call someone the wrong
name and don't realize I've done it
right.
Like jamie said,
you said jack.
Oh,
I thought I said john,
like we've had that conversation before.
I literally in my head think
I'm saying the right thing,
but I'm not.
I,
you know,
I made a huge,
huge mistake on one of my videos.
I deleted the video because of it because
instead of saying harvey weinstein,
I said,
brett,
oh no.
And brett's awesome brett.
Such a cool dude.
I'm a big fan.
And I published a video and someone
messaged me and they were like,
just want to let you know
you made this big mistake.
And I had some pretty awful
things and I felt so bad.
I think I've done similar.
I was like,
oh my god,
dude.
I was like,
that guy is so cool.
Like I'm a big fan of his work.
I just was like,
I tried editing it and I'm like,
I'm bleeding it hands down.
I would.
I would rather just remove the video
outright than to say a disparaging word
against that man.
And I was an accident.
I didn't even.
I didn't even know I said it.
I think I did the exact same thing.
I did the exact same thing,
I believe on stage once because I
had a bit about harvey weinstein.
I said,
brett,
I think I said it onto fortunate.
Yeah,
because they're polar opposites.
Yeah.
Brett's fantastic.
No,
he's actually weinstein,
right?
So that Will help.
Yeah.
Say stein instead of 18 for heartbeat.
No,
for brett,
for brent and eric weinstein.
Weinstein,
harvey weinstein,
bret weinstein.
I couldn't.
I didn't even know I did
it spelled the second I,
I edited the video.
I edit,
I edit.
I published it,
and then I started getting messages
from people and I was like,
no.
And then I watched the that.
Oh my god,
dude,
it's a problem.
You know,
like when you're Thinking
and talking at the same time,
there'S a bunch of words bouncing around
in your head and you're just trying to.
And you think you're saying the
right thing when you know it's.
That's why intent so critical.
George carlin.
Yeah.
And magic words are so fucking dangerous,
you know,
and that is what I'm going
to tell you about later on.
Yeah.
You know about a specific
comedian that we know and love.
Well,
george carlin was
absolutely amazing.
Well,
he was.
He not only was he absolutely amazing,
but people don't have to you.
You almost have to have lived during the
time where he was getting arrested just
much like lenny bruce before him,
but to understand how significant he
was when he was doing that seven dirty
words,
you can't say on television,
like back then people were like,
what the fuck is this guy doing?
It was groundbreaking when he did a,
I think it was in [inaudible] 92.
He did that bit.
We probably did it a lot where he
basically ran off 50 racial slurs and then
actually called eddie murphy
and richard pryor the n word.
Remember that school?
Yes,
and everyone laughed.
Yeah.
Everyone left because they
understood his intent.
They understood that he didn't
actually disrespect them.
They understood that.
He didn't mean anything bad about it.
He was making a point about the the
racist asshole behind the words,
and it's funny to me.
This is the thing,
man.
I,
when I was younger I was.
I was far left men skin tight,
black shirts,
the virus,
a virus,
the punk rock bands,
aunties,
lab,
things like that.
I was trying to think of.
It's been so long.
I'll try to think of some of the band
shirts we used to have and a man we were.
We were angry and pissed off all the time.
I grew up like that and
then over time I learned I.
I went through a ton of
really important life lessons.
One of the first and most important was
I was a young skateboarder in chicago.
Really looked up to some of these,
these older guys who were really good.
I went to catholic school
when I was younger.
I ended up becoming this punk rocker
guitar playing far left skin tight,
you know,
skateboarding,
angry,
no flags,
you know,
fuck the government,
and then I go to this dude's house
was just really great skateboards,
got a picture of jesus on the
wall and I immediately scoff like,
um,
you know,
high and mighty.
I was like,
it's like,
what do you,
what do you like a christian or something?
And he goes,
no,
and I was like,
why?
You have a picTure of jesus?
And he goes,
oh,
I just thought like a story about a dude
travel around helping people was kind
of cool.
And I went,
oh,
that's a good point.
Wow.
I was.
I was like,
wow,
maybe I don't really understand.
Maybe maybe this means something
different to other people.
That means to me,
well,
if jesus was an indian man that
had wooden beads and you know,
in he was a hindu god,
we would love him.
You know,
it'd be like shiva or vishnu.
We would,
we would think he's the
most amazing thing ever.
It's the fact that if you look at what
jesus preached and what he was all about,
I mean,
seems pretty rad.
I think it's about as
spiritual and loving and it's,
it's about,
I mean it,
his,
his whole ideology that the jesus of
the bible and he was essentially about
loving your brother and treating
people as if they're you and,
but this,
this for me,
like I bring this up because it was kind
of a formative moment where all of a
sudden I realized was my
ideology predicated on
assumptions was I was I holding
these views because other
people told me to hold them,
that actually understand that there were
some positive things on the other side.
And then I slowly moved over to
more of a center left position.
And you know,
now what the reason I bring this up.
as I looked,
I watched that video.
I tweeted this,
the video of george
carlin [inaudible] man.
George carlin was,
uh,
I used to watch this video was my,
my,
my mom would put them on and
my mom's been a hippie liberal,
far left,
all that stuff and you'd probably
consider a conservative by today's,
you know,
measures the way things have been going.
Now they look at,
you know,
Kevin Hart,
he's had a bad joke 10 years ago.
Get 'em out.
Like,
could you imagine?
I,
god forbid what would happen with
george carlin's routines today?
They wouldn't,
they,
they would be running all
of his old routine saying,
no,
you have to ban him from the show.
he literally called
these people the n word.
Why was it that george carlin can go
on stage and talk about how republicans
were dominant,
how religion is crazy.
He was clearly on the left his whole
life and he said these things that by
today's standards would be
considered conservative.
Right.
And so for me it's a weird thing to
go from being on the far left as a,
as a young person.
It was around like 19 or 20.
I started to become more moderate and
then to see them today being extremely
offended like people used to
be in the fifties and sixties,
like that's regressive,
that's trying to bring things back to
the way they used to be with offensive,
nothing on puritanism and all
these things and now I feel like,
I guess the cliche is the modern,
the modern left,
whatever people call it,
like the capital l tribal left seems to
be being indoctrinated not by leftwing
policy ideas.
It's not about necessarily socialism,
it's about identitarianism.
It's about policy based on your immutable
characteristics and how you know,
like going back to the green new deal,
like in the bill it talks
about racial equity.
What does that do to the environment,
but what does that mean?
Well,
equality would be like you,
you equal opportunity to.
People are allowed to
try and if one succeeds,
congratulations,
equity would be well,
let's determine whether or not you are
advantaged or privileged and then hold
you back or push you
forward based on these,
these certain metrics.
I suppose it's,
it's the problem I have with it
is that it's not quantifiable.
so this was actually something
that was really shocking to me.
I was siTting with my niece,
uh,
and my,
my sister,
my niece and my mom and I showed
this image that people like to share.
It's three people
standing up by a baseball,
a fence,
and there's a,
there's a baseball game as a
really short person who can't see.
There is a medium sized person who can
see a little bit and a very tall person
who just stands right up above the fence.
It says this is equality.
Each of them gets one crate,
one crate isn't enough for the short guy
and the two guys can already see that
says this is equity.
And it shows the short guy getting,
you know,
three crates so they can all see now.
And I said,
the problem is when it
comes to someone's height,
sure we can understand,
let's,
let's give the crates to the short
guy so he can see along with us.
But how do you determine equity based
on the color of someone's skin or their,
you know,
like characteristics that can't
necessarily be quantified.
Right?
So when alexandria ocozzio cortez pushes
a bill ford that's purporting to be
about the environment,
but includes racial equity clauses,
are we to assume that her ideology states
that if you are not white are poor by
like it's a guarantee or do we have to
assume that each individual has different
advantages,
different cards to play
and some are born wealthy,
some aren't.
And yes,
there's historic racism,
but We can't make those assumptions.
Right?
Right.
So this is,
this is,
to me one of the biggest problems
I've been having as like a lifelong
left-leaning individuals
who do I vote for it?
Right?
I was a big fan of bernie
sanders for awhile,
but then bernie sanders gets up
on stage at the debates and says,
white people don't know
what it's like to be poor.
Well,
that's hilarious.
That is to go to fucking West
Virginia and visit the coal miners.
Right?
And you know what's really weird?
I saw one of bernie's
tweets that I looked at it.
I said,
oh,
come on man,
you know,
this is fucked up.
He was talking about how much more
money white men make than black women.
And latino men and all these different
things and what he didn't include was
asian men or asian men make more money.
But here's what I think a lot
of people on the right miss.
He said,
pay equity,
not pay equality.
Okay.
I think perhaps we should stop assuming
they don't know what they're saying
because a lot of people
assume what they're saying is,
you know,
the gender,
the gender earnings gap is,
is real,
but the gender pay gap,
it's not that if a man and a woman
are both offered the exact same job,
exact same experience and education,
women tend to get.
I think it's like three to five percent
less and many people believe that's
because they are less likely to negotiate.
WhIch is why you have like lean in tulum,
it'd be more,
you know,
trying to be more assertive,
but it's not this 77
percent number that's.
But there is an earnings gap,
right?
The median salaries of men
and women are different.
So when bernie says white men make x
more than these other demographics,
he said in his tweet,
pay equity,
not equality.
He doesn't want fair pay
for everyone based on job.
He's actually saying it doesn't
matter what job you have.
Everyone should be paid the same.
No,
that's nonsense.
But then you see what cortez
releases on our website.
If you're unwilling To work,
they'll provide economic security.
They actually,
my,
I believe they took it off the site,
right.
But I think when they include it
in the bill that they want equity,
not equality when they
include on their website.
If you're unwilling,
they'll pay you.
And when bernie says equity as well,
I think they're not talking about
equality like I don't think you know,
the average american understands what
they're actually saying is you should be
paid a flat rate period.
And when you're talking about the pay
gap being different from men and women,
we should clarify that.
What you're saying essentially is that
men choose different jobs and they work
more hours and that's the reason
why they make that much more money.
Where at seventy seven
cents On the dollar.
Yeah.
There,
there was uh,
an,
another study came out recently that
said that ours worked was almost the,
a 100 percent of the reason why
men and women earn different,
uh,
at a median median salary in some areas
a women actually earn more than men.
Uh,
and there's,
I think seven cities.
I think this was on pew.
Again,
you fact check me if you got everybody
thinks I'm wrong or whatever,
but uh,
I believe it was seven cities were women
out men by like seriously high numbers,
like up to 20 percent.
So there's a lot of issues when it
comes to the pay gap and equality.
But without going on a
tangent on that area,
I think what ends up happening is,
you know,
I saw bernie's tweet and I
responded to it by saying good news,
bernie pay equality is enshrined in law.
And I said,
I cited three examples of where it's
illegal to discriminate based on gender.
And then someone points out to me,
tim,
he didn't say quality is said equity.
That would imply,
doesn't matter what job you have in a
petroleum engineer should earn the same as
a store clerk at h and m.
That's equity that just
because you have an advantage,
because if education doesn't mean you
should earn more than somebody else.
You see what I'm saying?
So
the fact that there's people
that actually believed that,
that don't believe that
we're the first of all,
that's going to absolutely discourage
people from trying to succeed.
Why would you,
if you could get the same amount
as the ceo of exxon as you can,
working at 21 forever,
forever 21 or whatever,
abercrombie and fitch.
WhY would you,
why would you try hard?
Why would you?
Why would you succeed?
Why would you excel?
I think it's fair to point
out some people would love it.
What if there's no.
If there's no real,
I mean other than social status,
if there's no real positive,
I think social status might be one
of the prime driving factors of,
of most people at whole.
No man,
not enough.
Not enough to really encourage
innovation and progress.
I,
I can agree with that for sure,
but I also think there's a,
there's a saying that I was told a lot
that people don't get rich because they
want money,
they get rich because they're passionate
about something and the money comes
after,
you know,
they always say that the money comes
after something like that and I point out
every,
every day I take no days off.
It's been a couple years with
me not taking any days off.
I work literally every day full time.
Right now I'm Producing six
youtube videos every day.
Only one of them is a
real seven days a week,
seven days a week,
nonstop for two years straight.
Fuck you do on yourself.
I like it.
It's fun and that's the thing.
I'm not,
I'm not doing it.
you're enjoying this lady down the tunnel.
I do it because you know,
I see things on a.
So for the most part on
my main youtube channel,
I do one video every day at 4:00 PM,
which tends to be just
like a news analysis piece,
but I'm not perfect.
Sometimes I get all hyperbolic and stuff.
My second channel is me
just ranting and you know,
not really swearing but still
just like heavy opinion stuff.
I do it because it's fun,
you know,
I see something.
I want to explore it.
A,
I used to travel all the
time when I worked at vice,
I was in all these different countries
and all these dangerous places,
not because I wanted to
have a name for myself,
not because I wanted to make money,
I wanted to watch her evolution,
I want to know why it was happening and
I want to talk to the people who were
experiencing it so I can,
I can,
I can relate to people who say
money isn't a motivator for sure,
but I've also talked to
people in scandinavia who
have told me they sort of give
up at a certain point because I
can't remember which country it was.
It may have been Sweden or Norway,
but these two women toLd me that
after like $77,000 per year,
they tax lIke 80 percent of your income.
So people just stopped.
They literally just stopped that.
That's
another proposition,
right.
This is something else that's
been discussed in terms
of anyone who makes more
than x amount per year taxing over 70
percent.
So I agree with the
progressive tax wholeheartedly.
I disagree with that number of that high.
What do you think it should be?
I don't.
I don't know,
but I will say we need
more progressive brackets.
We need to keep going and you know,
I got to say maybe maybe at $10,000,000,
70 percent does make sense,
but I kind of leaned towards not
really because it seems like man,
that's a lot of money.
That's a lot.
That's,
that's,
that's ridiculous amount.
You know,
I think steve bannon said something
like a five in front of it or something,
but I don't know.
I'm not an economist,
but I do believe a progressive
tax makes the most sense.
And I can explain it to
you if you want to hear it.
Sure.
So there was a study,
I,
I believe it was from harvard,
you need $77,000 per year.
It may have been 10 years ago in order
to be middleclass median in the United
States.
That means if you make 77,000
and you'll have a vacation,
you'll have insurance,
you'll have a car,
you can raise a family,
you can send them to school,
all that stuff,
but you have nothing
left over for savings.
You have nothing left
over for investments.
If you make $100,000 a year,
you're gonna have $23,000
leftover for investing.
Eventually at a certain point,
if you only need $77,000,
if you're making 10 million,
you've got 9 million,
900 and 900,000 that you can invest and
just be independently wealthy and be
rich forever.
Now,
I have no problem with being wealthy.
I have no.
I have no problem with other people
being wealthy and living off of their
investments and all that,
but there is a point where
you have to realize the,
the,
the coalescing of power,
the monopolizing of power is a really
dangerous thing for any society to few
individuals holding too much
power can destabilize an economy,
can destabilize the country.
The problem with communism,
you snap your fingers and you put
a centralized authority in place.
At least that's how it's
been every single time,
and then they hold all the
cards and they can oppress over.
They want the problem with laissez faire.
Capitalism has over time,
which is why it's better in a lot of ways.
Over time.
It eventually becomes a
centralized oligopoly of a
few corporations controlling
everything,
which we're kind of seeing now.
So all the progressive tax can
really do is slow that process down,
which I think is a good thing.
But ultimately I think
just looking at the system,
eventually you end up
kind of where we are,
where six media companies control
everything and then you know,
some companies are the biggest funders
of certain politicians and corporations.
It's have too much power.
I mean,
there,
there is,
uh,
I,
I remember reading a report or a story
about how wealthy people have like three
or four times more ability to influence
a politician than like the majority of
the people in the country simply
because paying for expensive dinners and
lobbying earns you favors,
you know,
super pacs paying,
guaranteeing funding for,
for a politician or as your favorites.
So it's,
you know,
look,
if a million people
telling me they want x,
but the people who are paying me like pa
funding my campaign are paying me more,
well,
who am I going to provide favors too?
And then once I'm done
with my campaign run,
I can go to job at their company.
Yet these are problems.
So without going on too big of a rant,
I think ultimately a progressive tax can
help slow the process down of special
interests,
acquiring too much power.
Eventually it happens anyway.
But with a flat tax,
you're basically saying at a certain
point you can just keep dumping more and
more money into different investments.
Making more and more money and increasing
your power exponentially and other
people can't catch up to you and
then power becomes too quick,
right?
Yeah.
I think in this country we try to look
at success and achievement is something
that everyone's striving for it and we
don't want to put any restrictions on
that.
We look At capitalism is the reason why
everything's going so great over here.
This is America.
Atlanta,
the free home of the brave.
Go out there and kick ass.
We're not going to
saddle you now with debt,
but it makes sense that after
a while as we're seeing today,
but I don't mean what is,
what's the best way to do it
in socialism is not gonna work.
What,
what,
what does work?
I think a mixed economy,
mixed economy where we are right now,
right?
A portion of income is paid in taxes
for government programs for the,
for the,
uh,
for defense and things like that.
I just think we have a big
problem with corruption.
I think we've got bloat.
I think we've got government agencies
that instead of reforming and breaking
them down,
we just slept more bandaids on top.
Yeah,
we've got a festering wound and
we're putting bandages over bandages.
you know,
it's like a certain point.
You gotta redo it.
We also have system
that are in place that.
I mean in terms of like the way
communities have always existed in certain
communities.
There's just poverty and crime and
no one does anything to fix it.
Right,
and it seems to be that will.
We're more than willing to go to other
countries and nation built were more than
willing to pump money
into different countries,
especially if they have natural resources,
but in our own country,
we're not mean the the greatest resources
of course human beings and the best
way to make America great or stronger
would be to have less losers or what's the
best way to have less losers,
to have more people succeed.
What's the best way to
have more people succeed?
Give them more opportunity and
chance to not be stuck in a quagmire,
not be trapped in a ghetto.
This is,
yeah,
so I believe we should allocate
access from other areas to improve the
areas.
In that sense,
I believe in socialism to a
certain extent like it with,
with fire departments.
I Believe in it with
the police department.
I believe we should spend
money that comes out of,
you know,
the publIc pool to fix things.
Right.
I look at New York,
there are some neighborhoods
that are really bad.
Some neighborhoods that are really good.
well if we take excess from the really
great neighborhoods and use that to fix
roads,
pay for schools in poor neighborhoods,
crime is one of the biggest
correlations for crime and poverty.
Yes.
So if we can get better schools,
we need to reform the
school system straight up.
If we can get better hospItals,
if we can fix the roads,
then we're doing a lot to reduce crime
and reduce poverty and a rising tide
lifts all ships.
So that's why I.
That's why I like bernie sanders,
although I will,
I say I make sure I tell people
like he is a little too left for me.
He is,
but when we,
when we were looking
at who we had in 2016,
I was like,
yeah,
bernie's my guy,
you know,
I like some parts of them.
I liked him culturally.
I liked to,
you know,
for the same
in some ways that I
liked obama culturally.
I mean,
I don't the drone attacks,
I don't like the attacks
on whistleblowers.
There's a lot of aspects of it that I've
found very disturbing and distasteful
and against the narrative of
what we think of who he is.
We think of him as this
extremely articulate,
very well read educated guy and you know,
a good,
a good figurehead in terms
of like who the president is,
right?
Right.
But,
and he was drowned
bombing foreign countries.
His administration was claiming that
military aged men who were enemy
combatants,
you know,
so one of the,
one of the biggest age men period,
right?
Right.
So it's like a dude carrying water
pills gets blown up and they're like,
as a combatant realization.
And so,
you know,
when it comes to trump,
what did he do in missile strike in Syria?
Weapons deal with Saudi Arabia.
Commando raids in Yemen,
a little girl got killed and
I've been for the most part,
very,
very critical of him in any
other administration who
engages in regime change
foreign wars.
And look,
I got to say,
you know,
when it comes to domestic issues,
I'm not,
that's not my wheelhouse when it
comes to foreign policy stuff.
Only a little bit like I've
been to some countries,
I've experienced stuff,
but really,
you know,
on the ground cultural between
people is more my thing.
But I know more about
foreign policy than domestic.
And when I see trump's foreign policy,
I was very critical of it.
But I will point out
withdrawing from Syria,
I'm a fan.
Um,
I understand a lot more than
probably the average person does.
Some of the issues surrounding Syria,
Russia,
the Qatar,
Turkey pipeline and things.
But typically I think it's usually a bad
idea when the u s involves itself's in
foreign foreign interests and
tries engaging in these regimes,
change strategies to build allies.
But one of the things that really
blew my mind is I saw a survey,
at least it was going on in
the inner on social media.
So who knows if it's true that claimed
the democrats have a favorable opinion of
george w dot bush,
you know,
some something to that effect.
And they're there in retrospect like,
yeah,
like today they pulled them,
they're like,
oh,
he was good.
And there's a video of him like giving
a piece of candy to Michelle Obama.
And everyone was like,
what's going viral?
And people are laughing about.
I'm like,
are you not?
Say hold hands.
That's crazy.
That guy is awful like that guy.
But what happened?
And then when trump announces he's
going to pull troops out of Syria,
everybody opposes it,
like the media saying it's wrong and
you've got a lot of like mainstream people
on the left saying it's wrong.
And I'm like,
it is,
what do you mean?
Like that's crazy to me.
Like,
you know,
uh,
all of my activist friends,
we've never been in favor of that stuff.
We've always opposed.
That's always been the left's position.
And now I'm seeing people who claim to
be on the left support multinational
businesses as private businesses
doing whatever they want,
meaning look,
social media,
corporate,
like,
like dude,
you know,
Saudi Arabia,
I think it's a saudi prince is one
of the biggest investors in twitter.
Real.
Yeah.
And so it's like there have been a series
of people who have gotten letters that
they violated pakistani law.
I mean,
they,
they send screenshots,
screenshots can be faked.
But there've been a couple
of people who have been like,
for some reason twitter
decided to inform me of this.
And then it's,
it's,
it's a multinational.
Let's,
let's talk about the
algorithmic apocalypse.
Let's segue into that.
You've got a platform where our public
discourse is happening where the left has
repeatedly said that russians
used it to manipulate our elections were
one of its biggest investors is a saudi
prince or something to that effect.
And they're banning.
People have,
have a certain,
uh,
who oppose a certain ideological bent.
Right?
That sounds like a democratic crisis,
right?
If,
if this is where the public sphere is,
if you know you said milo's
no longer in the conversation,
you know,
he's banned from twitter even
though got millions of followers,
they don't talk about him anymore.
He's off twitter.
Twitter really is important.
The president is there.
So if you start removing people,
you've got foreign interests who have
a stake in what twitter is doing.
Yeah,
they can seriously
influence our elections and,
and,
and they,
they are.
But I'll,
but I'll,
but I'll move into a what most
really crazy New York times reported.
There's a group that false flagged the
republicans in Alabama with fake twitter
accounts they made to convince the media.
Russians were propping up
the campaign of Roy Moore.
So basically this coordinator
times is all fact this.
They've seen the documents,
they've reported it,
that democratic operatives smeared,
uh,
engaging a false flag campaign to make
it appear like the russians were popping
up.
Republicans and the national
media in the us ran with it.
How that's not a crime is beyond me that's
interfering in elections and we know
it.
And this group is still being cited.
They're smearing tulsi gabbard,
right?
Yeah.
An nbc news article came out
saying that russians are,
you know,
have taken notice of her campaign,
are promoting it.
Same group,
still running the story.
How,
how that's not a crime
is mind blowing to me.
But the New York times reported it.
So it's at this point it's like,
I mean,
that's,
I think we have to be aware that there's
so much manipulation going on right now
from almost every angle.
Oh yeah.
So I mean,
and what's hilarious is that people look
at what's going on with russian troll
factories and you know,
the way they're trying to
influence our elections,
that it's particularly
egregious where we do that shit.
I'll totally plus.
And I'm pretty sure we learned about
the us doing it well before we learned
Russia was doing it and I'd be
willing to bet the us started it.
It's just the whole thing is.
So you can't pay attention to all of it.
That's part of the problem.
Yeah.
I mean,
maybe you can,
if this is what you're
doing seven days a week and,
and even,
you will probably struggle to keep up,
but like me,
I can't and it's one of the reasons why
I brought you in here when you and I had
that conversation.
One of the first things I
realized right away was,
oh,
okay,
I could have you coach me
like we talked about this,
but I'm not going to.
I'm like,
I'm not going to get it all.
I'm going to have to like study it
for a long time and I don't have the
resources to do that as part of the
problem that I had with that one podcast
with jack.
I just don't have the resources and yes.
Um,
so I think it'd be fair to point out,
you know,
like youtube criticism too
because talking about censorship,
I think a lot of people immediately
assumed I'd come out here and start waving
my arms in the air screaming.
They're biaSed against conservatives,
which I think twenty cent I kind of did.
but youtube is,
as is a bit different.
Youtube does,
it has demonetized lgbt content and
youtube has said that these topics are not
suitable for all advertisers
because it deals with sexuality.
They have target many left wing channels,
there are a lot of non
mainstream left wing outlets.
And when you say target,
what you mean is demonetize do you
monetize or sometimes outright ban?
And I think for demonetizing
I think they've made a stick.
What was the,
uh,
the policy that it's essentially
things that are political.
Correct.
If they made that statement,
I know that I've seen I was,
wasn't,
I was going to interject that
they've also banned are not banned,
but do you monetize?
PeopLe are extensively people
that smoke weed on their channel,
totally.
Certain video game channels that have for
an unknown reasons just stopped having
a monetization on their channel too.
Right?
And that is the problem.
Ultimately them having this
incredible power where they,
they really,
there's no,
there's not real open competition
in terms of like another,
like a parallel competitor and I
don't think there will be mailing but.
But here's the thing,
I,
I think you've touched on a
bunch of really bad things.
I'm going to give a,
a very important shout
out to monkey jones,
who was wrongly terminated from
youtube for highly dubious reasons.
He Is a dark,
dark,
comedic,
dark comic.
He had hundreds of thousands of followers.
He made jokes about things
like school shootings,
very dark stuff,
but it was clearly mocking.
Some of these people was
mocking elliot roger.
He was making jokes about it and in
fact some of his videos were approved
manually for monetization,
but for some reason youtube just
wiped them out one day gone.
So I set up a new channel and said,
okay,
you know,
we're not going to do that anyway.
Doesn't matter.
They got rid of him.
He's effectively off of youtube.
And he was like,
he's a,
he's a well known funny guy.
He wasn't breaking the rules,
he wasn't,
but they still deleted,
deleted his channel.
So I bring him up because I
think it's worrisome that yes,
without an alternative,
you're career is wiped out in a second
with no recourse and no reason why.
And the response they give you as it's
our platform and you'll hear people say,
oh,
but there are private business,
they can do what they want short,
but they're a monopoly.
We've got to have restrictions on that.
Yeah,
yeah.
Sorry,
I have a question to ask here because
I've had this conversation with some
friends of mine and this came up in like,
this is,
I guess the devil's advocate to this
question because this happened with my
space.
My space still exists and there are
people that had millions of followers on
that platform.
Are they owed something by my space
because my space failed and their,
their accounts no longer have
the clout that they once had.
No.
You know,
like.
So if for instance,
like if youtube failed,
tomorrow is pooty pie,
sue them because they've made bad
business decisions and now for an issue.
Totally,
totally different.
I know that.
I see what you're sending
the twitter account,
like they're not banning someone's ip
address from using twitter.com and go into
c slash real Donald Trump
and see what he's saying.
But listen,
your myspace failed
because of alternatives.
Facebook became more prominent,
there was an option
and the other issue is monkey
jones followed the rules.
He was,
he told by youtube,
this is what you can
and can't do anything.
You got it.
And then one day they just wiped him out.
and so then they'd never
gave any explanation.
I don't believe so.
And it was reallY weird because,
and uh,
I,
it's been a little while,
so I went over the story,
but there was a video he posted that was
like a music video making fun of elliot
roger.
He's that school that,
that administrator guy,
it existed on different channels on other,
like another prominent channel it
existed and they banned him and then he
brought up like why was it banned on mine?
But this one was approved.
and then a day later
they band the other one.
They copyright struck it.
The issue here is if there was an
alternative to youtube you where you can
operate,
I'd be on it,
right?
so,
um,
one of the things I'll give a shout out,
I've been using minds,
am I mds?
I'm actually having build
the guy that owns it.
How do you spell your last name?
Altman altman.
Bill altman's coming on soon.
I'm a,
I made a concerted effort after that
podcast to reach out to a bunch of
different people and try to
expand this conversation.
I want to have the guy from gab to gaps,
gaps in murky,
you know,
a gab has been murky in terms
of content but not really.
I don't think so.
Um,
so I did it.
I researched this a little bit.
If you look at their wikipedia page,
It's simple sourcing.
They um,
there was a study done on gab that found,
I think they only have like five percent
of the posts are considered to be hate
speech,
whereas twitter is like two
point three or something.
So gab is predominantly not hate speech,
not much more than twitter.
And when you consider that
we're looking at percentages,
you can actually see that twitter is hate
speech isn't the millions and gabs is
in the tens of thousands,
but gab is run,
you know,
volume.
the media nonstop.
Yes.
Men,
I think when it comes to youtube,
I actually,
I actually trust them.
I do,
I really do.
I think the reason they took on monkey
is because the potential for a pr
backlash over his kind
of content was so great.
They said,
we don't care and that's
unfair and it's wrong.
I think they were wrong and do it,
but,
but you understand the motivation.
I understand the motivation and I actually
think youtube does more to protect
free speech on the internet than
a lot of these other companies do.
when a.
And I'll give you a few example.
I'll get,
I'll get one good example is first of all,
when you're demonetized you
still earn youtube red revenue,
so youtube still will,
like they're trying to pay you.
they want the money.
But uh,
with sargon avocado getting banned from
patrion patrion banned him because they
said you used the naughty word
on youtube eight months ago.
Youtube doesn't care.
He said the word right.
Is that the pod where you called that?
The outright,
the white end word you didn't care.
Youtube said it's,
it's fine on a platform that,
that's fine,
that's fine.
Pastry set the context and the
context of which it was used to.
It just takes 30 seconds
listening to it go,
oh,
I see what he's doing.
Even if it's kind of a
clunky use of the word.
He's not using it in a race racist,
racist way.
He was trying to,
you know,
uh,
actually this is,
he was trying to show how stupid they are,
but can we talk about the bias on twitter
with sara jong who for three years
with posting anti white
racist like mean spirited,
awful things.
And the excuse was she was using
the language of our oppressors.
yeah.
Well we think sargon was doing.
He was using their language against them.
Exactly.
They hire at the New York times.
Yes.
That's,
that's terrifying.
And there was a huge backlash there and
I don't want to take this opportunity
to,
to point out media matters.
There was when that thing went around
the alternative influence network lying,
like there was a media
matters wrote about it.
I politely reached out to the person
who did and their response was,
I hope a bird poops on your head and it
gets in your eyebrow and you smell like
farts.
That was,
that's the response they gave me.
What?
Yeah.
I said,
just want to give you a heads up.
There's a lot that's wrong in this report.
It's not true.
My dental hold these beliefs.
I've never had this individual.
And that was,
that was the response to literal response
was I hope a bird poops on your poops
on you and it falls into your eyebrow
and you smell like a dirty farts or
something.
Then when I,
when I,
uh,
I,
so,
so yeah,
I mean I got a hold of their fucking
typewriter or keyboard rather than.
And you know,
I'm the guy who started it was at a
political and he and he set up on stage.
Fake news is predominantly it's.
He said it's only,
it's only a phenomenon of the right to
the left doesn't engage in conspiracies
and fake news,
which is nonsense.
Of course they do.
And I afterwards,
I said,
let me ask you then because one of your
writers responded to me in this way and
he's like,
I don't know anything
about it and I can respond.
And then he walked off and I was like,
you know,
I want to circle back to gab because I
get what you were saying that the volume
is lower and that there's less
I read.
Right.
What do you,
what is your opinion of it though?
You were kind of.
We kind of got sidetracked.
Oh,
it's a,
it's.
I don't,
I don't know.
I,
I can agree with the general notion,
the ideology of if it's legal,
it's allowed.
Um,
and I would,
I would argue that,
you know,
what jack is trying to do with
twitter or I would say him personally,
but what twitter is trying to
do is what create like a comfy,
padded neon room for
the kids to hang out at.
NoW.
The real world is harsh.
I think what they're trying to do,
and I don't want to speak for him,
but I think they're trying to engineer
the conversation to be more polite and
civil says who exactly,
you know,
whose,
whose definition?
That's a good point.
And that's,
and that's,
that's.
I see so many of these people who just,
they wield power and
they're unaccountable.
Well,
it's also you don't recognize
the consequences of telling
people what they can
and can't do and that it's.
This is a very slippery slope.
You running up a greased hill.
Yeah,
and people don't like it.
They don't like it and well the,
the thing is like
when you see something,
like if,
if everything was just open,
what would the conversation be
like if there was no banning,
if there was nothing,
it was just everything was real
free speech you would have.
I mean if it was,
if it was impossible,
let's put it this way,
it was impossible to ban someone
from any social media platform,
whether it's youtube or
twitter or instagram.
What would the conversations look like?
How much dIfferent would they be and
would we maybe have a healthier way of
adjusting?
I think it would be worse,
worse because I could,
I could be temporary or in the long run,
maybe temporary,
but there,
I believe it's called the
online inhibition effect.
Basically the opportunity to be
anonymous online and the and the and the
distance makes people.
They have no problem being their worst
self and so I can understand what twitter
wants to do.
They say,
hey,
we need to figure out how we stop people
from being mean all the time because
twitter is,
it's a hellscape of just mean people
saying nothing but mean things,
but it's also again,
because they're anonymous
and because it's possible.
But then look,
alex joneS can,
can say a bunch of really awful things.
It's his right to do so.
Should it be bent?
He shouldn't.
If,
if so it does.
Does Alex Jones?
Uh,
I'm not.
I don't want to directly accused
him because I don't watch his show.
But if he goes on twitter and he says
something that's deemed to be false shitty
band for that,
now if he,
if he challenges the journalists
should be banned for that.
No,
because let me tell you,
because he says thIngs
about me that aren't true.
I don't think it should be right.
I think,
and he's saying the things about me
and I don't think he should be banned.
I think alex,
I think we should talk,
have a conversation.
I watched those videos.
He's upset,
he's upset,
and I get it in certain ways.
I get it and he thinks I took a shot at
him and I get it and I probably did and
I shouldn't have.
So.
So here's,
here's the thing,
the,
my point is I don't think
you should be banned.
Right?
And it's,
he's doing it at me.
yeah.
Yeah.
I'm like,
I mentioned those people from occupy
who lie about me all the time.
They've posted the most
ridiculous lies about me.
I still don't think it should be banned.
right?
Does.
The thing is if you ban them
and then someone opposes them,
but then someone opposes the people who
oppose them and they want them banned,
and then you have this
fucking war back and forth,
and instead of fighting bad
ideas or incorrect ideas
with correct or good ideas,
now you just have people present.
Banhammer Is left and right and you're
just trying to figure out who the
majority is so you can side
with the biggest group,
but then you're trying to virtue signal
and you're trying to get something that
supports your ideology,
whether it's right or left.
So.
So here's the thing with jones though,
if the people on the left one to argue
that he is making the platform worse and
horrible,
I understand that and I recognize,
well that's unfortunate,
right?
This is the real world.
And sometimes people say
things you don't like,
but more importantly,
a lot of people argued that when he,
when he said that,
he said something about sandy hook,
which again,
I haven't seen the videos but they've,
they've been sued.
They said that.
He said,
daniel never happened.
So,
so what is fake news to be banned?
While many people were saying,
yes,
facebook needs to ban a fake news.
But think about what that means.
It means you're not allowed to be wrong.
Okay?
Because fake news doesn't
mean you did it on purpose.
More importantly,
you're not allowed to be stupid.
Well,
here's another thing
again in defense of alex,
one thing that alex did
do is in the future after,
after he was done saying the things
that he said about sandy hook,
he then said it definitely happened.
So he corrected his course and there's no.
Is there a path for redemption when you
correct your course and if there's not,
what are we doing?
Because we're not treating
people like human beings.
Then whether it's my
low or whether it's anybody.
I mean,
I'm sorry to cut you off at the path
to redemption is so fucking critical.
Yes,
so let me tell you,
I went to Sweden.
People were claiming things were
happening in Sweden a couple of years ago.
I decided to go check it out.
For some reason a bunch of people
believe that I pushed them far right?
Far right wing conspiracy
when I actually pushed him.
What was that?
You pushed a conspiracy theory or theory.
So,
so,
so.
So basically you had Donald
Trump said last night in Sweden,
as soon as he says this,
the media goes wild.
My friend and I and my friend emily
who works with me on an off set,
we're like,
we should just go to Sweden and just
like walk around film stuff and make a
video about what we experienced was that
to go almost immediately it's reported.
We found nothing.
We found the neighborhoods
were actually very nice,
substantially nicer than chicago,
but we did find there was an increase in
crime is very tepid for some reason now
people are claiming that like I'm
pushing conspiracies or something.
I was going to go somewhere that,
but I kind of lost my train of thought.
Had a.
Oh,
okay,
here we go.
When I was there,
joey salads is a big youtuber.
Reached out to me on twitter saying,
hey,
I'm here to let's meet up.
I got really angry because joey salads
made a video I think a couple years ago
where he staged a bunch of black guys
destroying a car to make it seem like
these,
these neighborhoods where black people
were going to destroy trump car and it
was like,
it was very racist as awful.
Horrible.
Yeah.
He's a big youtuber and so he reached
out to me and I got really pissed.
Like,
dude,
you're fake news.
You're a racist.
And I was like,
and I just,
I started cussing at him.
I was like this and
that's not normal for me,
but that.
But afterwards I kind
of realized something.
Joey made a mistake,
he reached out to me.
It was polite.
He was honest.
I think he did something really,
really bad.
If I tell him,
if I've cussed them out,
if I just be mean to him,
what's he going to do?
The Only people who will accept him.
If the only people are going to be
nice to him or the actual racists will,
then he's going to go to the racists.
He needs a path to redemption.
So I.
So I apologized and I said that was wrong.
I shouldn't have done that.
I should.
I should be willing to hear you out
and I should give you an opportunity to
better yourself.
Otherwise you won't.
And then I Met up with them
and talk to them and I.
And I think he made a huge mistake.
I think what he did was wrong.
I think it was self motivated.
I think it was money motivated,
but I think none of that matters.
All that matters is you tell
them you do this one more time.
We're,
we're,
you're out.
You're out with the wolves.
But if you,
if you agree to do the right thing and
you're willing and you're sincere than.
Okay,
good for you.
I think that's got to be a
part of the conversation.
Yeah,
I mean we,
I think this idea of just
banning people for life,
but letting people out of jail after
they commit murder and they can reenter
society.
I mean it's still as hard
for them for a long time.
Like exxon show,
it's not easy,
but they're saying that
there's a path to redemption.
But what ends up happening is
they create parallel economies.
They create parallel networks
and that causes more division,
more anxiety.
Like you see,
you see these alternative social networks
emerge because People get banned.
So they all moved to one place.
This is back to gab.
Yeah.
So,
but you know,
I think gab is mostly gotta be honest.
I don't surf
gab.
I've read what they've,
people have said about it,
but at this point I don't
trust a lot of the media.
I don't.
And that's not unique for me.
Most americans have unfavorable
gab or you mean everything,
what they've said about
gab and everything,
right?
I mean,
what's your opinion of gay?
you don't have like a clear opinion of it.
My opinion of gab is that they do allow.
There's a lot more people with extreme
views simply because it's illegal.
right?
So they go there naturally,
but based on what I've read about
it from like actual reports,
it's not substantially worse than twitter,
but it does allow them
as a big difference,
right?
Yes.
You can go on twitter,
you can get away with it for awhile.
Gab,
you just go on gab and save a bunch of
crazy stuff and unless you break the law,
there have been accusations leveled
against gap that they've actually dragged
their feet on getting rid of illegal
things like calls for violence,
you know,
but for the most part some things that
you cAn get kicked off or like doxing
and.
Yeah,
so that it's not the wild west,
but it's wilder.
But you know,
what the media,
these people and,
and,
and I want to say the media,
I specifically mean these digital New
York based outlets for the most part,
they like to say things like,
you know,
that guy who shot up at synagogue,
horrible,
just disgusting.
But they say gab user.
So,
and so a gab user.
He was,
he was a twitter user,
right?
It was oN twitter,
drank water.
He drank water.
Yeah.
You know,
who else drInk water?
Hitler.
Yep.
Boom.
There it is.
But it's,
it's,
it's crazy.
It's like,
come on man.
You know?
Um,
but I,
but I will recognize right now that,
uh,
at this point gab is,
it's,
yeah,
if you're going to go on there,
the media is going to accuse you
of every single name of the book.
I'm Sure you got to,
you know.
So I've had conversations
with people in here will,
they'll just immediately
started throwing out these,
these descriptions of what gab
is and what cab stands for.
And like,
okay.
I mean,
I had with barry weiss,
I was like,
I was going to say,
and some politicians.
That waS a woof.
that's all.
Just say woof woof.
Which part of the tulsi gabard toady?
I,
you know,
I.
Did you see what I'm jimmy?
Yeah,
jimmy did about it.
I was laughing the whole
time with jimmy dore.
Jimmy dore.
Fucking.
He's fucking great.
And the way he did it in
front of a live crowd.
Yeah.
And,
and,
but,
but here's the thing,
I got to say like I'm sorry to bury it
really did sound like you didn't even
know what the word meant.
Yeah.
Because if you say,
what does that word mean?
I'll tell you what I think it means.
I won't ask someone to
check the feed first.
Right.
So it's like.
And she also,
she's also been a drag because she did
a story where she used a satire tweet
from antifa or something.
I don't necessarily.
So she's had her share,
but you know,
I don't know.
She's been busted doing that too.
She's got caught with the antifa
antifa post on a wall that was like,
oh really?
It was a troll,
somebody,
somebody told it,
but you know,
that's what's so crazy is that
things are so fucking blurry.
It's hard to see the troll sometimes.
Oh yeah.
And so there in lies the big problem.
I mean,
my brother might be
one of the most notorious,
not notorious the wrong word because he,
he like of hides in the shadows,
but he's done some.
My brother cloned a while,
I can't remember which website.
He cloned a website,
right?
The actually the yes
man recently did this.
Well we can post copied perfectly and he
wrote an article about how a new strain
of marijuana was discovered.
Cannabis,
australia's.
He said that he was the dean
at the university of sydney
or something like that.
Who was dating popstar meghan trainor,
just the most ridiculous
thing and that he said,
we need to find a female plant.
So far this what we have.
It's groundbreaking.
It's so,
so he did this very,
very clever thing.
He bought a domain name that was
something like calm-guest.info.
That's the url.
He then created a subdomain.
So it's like,
you know,
just hypothetically cnn.com,
dasha gassed,
the average person just see cnn.com.
They assume It's real.
I don't know how he shared it,
but he makes this whole.
It's so ridiculous,
man.
I got to say if you thought it was real.
I got a bridge cellular
high times picked it up.
It got 50,000 shares,
breakthrough,
new strain of marijuana.
Discovered.
My brother was just
laughing the whole time.
And I was like,
what did you do?
Like my brothers,
like my opposite,
you know,
I,
I try to be honest to
the best of my ability.
I,
you can,
you know,
I think,
people accused me of being a liar.
That's not fair.
I could be wrong for sure,
but I try my best to be rational.
My brother on the other
hand is like editing videos,
making them ridiculous as possible.
He made another video where,
and it's crazy because he
tries to make sure people.
It's over the top.
He made a video where it's
a van getting pulled over.
It looks like a police dash cam and
then the cop walks up to the car,
checks the guys licensed,
walks back,
and the driver releases pot on
a balloon and then an airport,
so it saying stash,
like he's disposing ms
drugs with helium balloons,
so they fly away and then
the cop runs up firing guns,
edit this thing,
got hundreds of millions of views.
It was on facebook every other day.
It's.
It was like he made it four years ago
or something and I saw it on instagram
like two weeks ago and I was like,
dude.
And I showed him.
People think it's real.
Like it's,
it's the craziest,
but he,
you know.
Yeah,
I dunno.
So,
so much fucked up stuff that is real.
It's so hard to differentiate what I mean.
Hold on.
Like let's,
let's throw some shade at high times.
Like when they did this,
they said they,
when they corrected the article
and saying it was a hoax,
they said we wanted to
call for verification,
but we thought the story
was too hot to pass up.
That's a really good example,
but that's a really good
example of covington.
It's a really good example of
what these news organizations do.
It's high times.
There were probably barbecue,
that mother fucking mind
when they wrote that,
and I say like,
they're not,
they're not the,
uh,
the bastions of great journalism.
We don't hold high times on a
pedestal next to the New York times.
Not to be disrespectful and
I respect the publication,
but the New York times
is the paper of record.
Yes.
At the same time,
if it's your job and you're
writing stories on a specialty,
like,
come on man,
but look,
this is,
uh,
there's,
there's two big things that affect
media that I think are worrisome.
Covington exemplifies really
well that people just wrote,
they didn't do any research
at all and it was all,
it was all wrong.
Then even watch the videos because
you can see in the first video,
not only that,
but what's even more egregious as they
did this several days right afterwards
and they were still like
the bill maher thing.
Yeah.
It's very unfortunate.
But then it's all avoidable if you're
going to discuss something and you're
going to do it in a public forum like
that and you know about it in advance.
This is not like you're on a
podcast ad libbing and you,
you say something and you mistake.
This is something that's planned.
The other thing that worries
me greatly is what we see with,
with,
uh,
learn to code,
right?
so this nbc reporter is,
he goes on this big twitter thread
about how twitter needs to take action
against these harassment campaigns.
And they refuSed to do it.
The next day he writes an article
citing an activist about how,
uh,
far right campaign and sending death
threats to journalists and twitters and
doing anything about it.
And after that he starts posting about
how he's getting death threats adapter
that twitter announces
they'll take action.
So what do we see here?
This guy called fraction,
couldn't get it done,
wrote an article,
slanting it as a far right
campaign against journalists.
Twitter decides to take action.
Now people are getting
banned for tweeting.
Learn to code.
This is people do think or
making these critical decisions.
I think it's a handful.
I mean,
I can't imagine twitter's
got a massive staff,
but like when you think
they have a huge staff,
what?
Couple hundred?
There's a hundred offices and
roughly 3,500 employees at those.
Oh,
okay.
So way more than I thought that was.
Yeah,
that's what I was 35 offices.
How many of those people are
operating in the bubble during.
In an ideological bubble,
but it's not just that,
you know,
you band kathy griffin,
she's a celebrity with
millions of followers.
They don't care about Alex Jones.
Alex jones sell supplements.
Right.
It's complicated.
I mean,
I can't really understand why he's.
Well,
he's more polarizing,
but he's also very famous.
Oh,
come on.
kathy griffin showed a photo
of Donald Trump with this,
you know,
with his head cut off,
which is even,
you know,
aren't so unless something really crazy.
The guy who wrote all
the articles demanding,
I don't to say demand
and that's maybe unfair.
Oliver darcy goes on cnn and says it
was media pressure that got jones' band.
He's the guy who
repeatedly wrote about it.
He was the guy.
Jones confronted about it.
Yes.
Oliver darcy interviewed me in 2016
about a video I made where I said it's.
It's worrisome that twitter is banning
people for their political ideologies.
Oliver darcy inter,
he,
I don't know if you interviewed me,
but he wrote an article about my video
and this is a journalist at business
insider who says,
oh,
that's a really interesting thing.
Tim,
let me write about your
take on what's happening.
And then two years later is,
is talking about how his media
pressure got jones' band.
It's like a weird one 80,
you know?
Wow.
Yeah.
So I'm not trying to be
disrespectful to him because I,
you know,
I know I'm somewhat in passing,
but I will say there's a certain point
where I think it's unfair to accuse a
journalist of advocating for
something simply for covering it.
But then he went on cnn And said it was
media pressure that got him banned and
I'm kinda like,
okay.
You have to realize at that point
you were the one who led that charge.
You know,
and you know,
I don't,
I don't care if you like them or not.
Banningham for for dubious reasons,
just creates huge problems.
It shows your bias,
but just saying it that way too.
It's like when hunter s thompson,
I'm spread the rumor about ed muskie
being on ibogaine and then he went on the
dick cavett show.
It's hilarious clip.
And he goes,
well actually there was a rumor,
there was a rumor about him being on.
I began to,
I know because I started
the rumor and you know,
I mean,
that's exactly,
that's kind of the same thing.
It's like,
yeah,
you,
you caused it.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You spread the rumor but that.
But there's another thing
too is I'm patrion band,
lauren southern,
I think it was like a year and a half,
two years ago.
And when she got banned it,
I don't know if you know what happened,
but she,
she went in the boat in the mediterranean.
And what was that?
She did something with the migrants.
She did,
she did a protest action with,
I believe it was generation identity,
which are,
um,
I don't know how to describe them because,
you know,
people like to throw labels around,
but they're like a european
nationalists and I,
I know people have called
them white nationalists,
but again,
I don't know enough about their group,
so I think it's fair to say that that's,
that might be the case.
Forgive me for being
ignorant for the most part,
but their ideology,
I know people are going to tear me apart.
She gets in a boat,
they go up to one of these.
My,
uh,
one of these migrant vessels that does,
they,
they say it's a search and rescue vehicle,
but this,
that's been a point of a debate and she
like waves a flyer in the air and then
she,
she says on the stream,
like get in front of them,
get in front of him.
But I believe she never did jack
connie banter and there are like,
what you're doing may
have caused loss of life,
your band.
A lot of people then started to point
out that there's a website called it's
going down and this is a,
you know,
consider to be far left.
Extremists site.
One of the articles was teaching people
or advocating for pouring concrete on
train tracks to disrupt,
derail the strains can cause loss of life.
So jack,
so I saw this and I thought
this is really fascinating.
I'd like to know why patrion band
southern and why they don't take action in
this regard.
I reached out to jack conti.
I tweeted at him,
he said he'd,
he'd,
he'd call me on the phone and I said,
you know,
I'd like to understand your,
your,
your decision making,
how this came to be,
what brought you to the
attention of lauren,
what about this?
He ended up banning,
iT's going down and then they wrote an
article titled tim pool and the alt right
get,
you know,
it's going down band
from patron or something.
And that's been cited.
Jimmy dore had it on his show
and a bunch of other like,
just,
you know,
temple's not outright.
And I said,
listen man,
I didn't advocate for them to be banned.
I don't want anyone band,
right?
I just want to know what their decision
making process was and this was the
thing that was going viral among
people on twitter who are or,
you know,
asking about this.
And so now I get accused of
campaigning to get them back just like,
you know,
I live for darcy was with,
with,
with um,
with jones,
but a well,
and then immediately they slapped
that distinction on you as soon as.
I mean just calling someone outright to.
It's so strange how,
you know,
I don't know if you know,
but all in the world of standup
comedy used to be progressive liberal,
like,
like weird coffee shop type rooms.
It was all comedy.
They don't even use that term
anymore because it's so toxic.
And I try to avoid saying I'll use
the alternative media all the time.
And this has happened over the
course of just a couple of years.
I mean,
the thing is shifted and it's moving
and evolving and morphing so quickly.
You want to know what's really crazy for
years on my wikipedia page at claimed
that I invented a zipline.
Zipline like a blimp.
Yes.
Yeah.
It's funny,
right?
Well,
wikipedia said I was Brian
Collins brother for decades.
Here's,
here's the thing.
When I went to Sweden,
I specifically stated,
uh,
let me,
let,
let me back up.
Paul Joseph Watson of info
wars put out a call saying,
I challenge any journalists to spend
a weekend in malmo and I'll cover your
costs.
Everybody's bombarding him saying,
oh,
pay me,
pay me.
And he's kind of just ignoring it.
People are threatening to sue him.
You better pay.
You promised.
I had already set up a go fund
me for the project before,
I believe it was before he announced
I made a video about it saying,
Donald Trump says x,
y,
and z.
We're going to go to the story.
When I saw he made this call,
I think it was actually
emily who noticed it.
I said,
hey,
I'll do it.
And he was like to be.
I think that's something like,
I was just taking the piss,
but yeah,
sure.
I'll send you a donation,
and I laughed and I was like,
hey man,
I'll take,
you know,
if he wants to throw my at my go fund me.
Here's what ends up happening
as people then claim I was uh,
I went there because Paul
Joseph Watson challenged,
challenged me.
Not true.
He donated about nine percent of our total
fund that we raised and I was already
planning on going there.
Wikipedia.
Uh,
there was a challenge on my
wikipedia page where they,
someone said,
you wrote tim pool went there because it,
paul just wasn't challenged him to.
That's not true.
What's your proof?
This youtube video from
tim pool where he sAys,
we've already arranged this.
We're not going here because of paul.
Joseph watson.
The response that's not a reliable source.
Someone came back with a reliable source,
you know it,
it was a huffington post article
that quoted my youtube video.
How's that?
I don't understand.
Why couldn't you just take my word for it?
Why did you have to get
huffington post to just quote me?
That was apparently so I,
you know,
that's enough.
I guess so.
So the reason I bring this up is
because what happens then if you're a
conservative and a bunch of friends who
work for various news organizations all
at the same time,
write 10 articles saying joe rogan is
all right now on wikipedia at 10 articles
pop up immediately saying this is a fact.
Ten different organizations have written
it and there it is in your and your
page.
And the crazy thing is the
uk does this all the time,
you know,
they call various personalities,
alt right?
They call sargon.
They call it [inaudible].
Just go to wikipedia and look up the
phrase it means white nationalists,
neo confederate.
It's like literally about
a white ethno state.
These people have denounced
this and that and you know,
it's like going to chicago was a really
fascinating phenomenon on patrion where
all of a sudden these left wing outlets
said sargon was banned for a going after
the alt right.
And I'm like,
well hold on.
You've wriTten in the past that he was.
All right.
Well when you say you like the
media is not the organization,
same organizations,
but different authors.
Well,
I don't wanna I don't want to,
but not the same journalists.
Um,
I,
I will lean towards,
I believe.
Yes.
Because it's,
it's,
it's so,
whenever it's convenient,
they just throw,
throw that.
There are some people who write.
The problem is if I may,
if I name these people,
they're going to,
they're going to point their pens in my
direction and then all of these things
are going to swing at me.
And the other thing too
is I don't want to do,
I don't want to forget them.
It's not important anyway.
What's really important is the actual
reality of how that's done there are,
I really want to name this organization.
It's one of the prominent well known,
but they repeatedly write stories
that are just so over the top.
I roll my eyes and I'm like,
do you will.
I will say The huffington post,
you know,
is another organization that wrote
like,
um,
oh god,
what was it?
Some,
some.
This guy wrote about nazis on steam
steam that steam has a knotty problem and
very clearly like anybody was like,
it was a game
because apparently he was
referencing a very small like,
here's what happens.
Okay.
I don't know too much about this.
I know there was criticism in the
journalism space around what he did,
but it's like you find three guys
on twitter who are saying something.
They quote,
tweet them and say boom,
fact like you find one guy who says,
you know,
I just plain don't like this group.
And they'll be like,
oh,
nazis don't like this group.
And they'll write a big story about
it because they found one tweet.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
So apparently,
you know,
this guy in the huffington post wrote
a story about how people on gab,
we're presenting really discussing
recipes for food and I'm just,
I'm wondering what's newsworthy about
a random gab users mascioli recipe.
Oh,
I saw that.
It was hilarious.
But,
but,
but then again,
is that comedy article?
Yeah,
it's an opinion piece.
It's just calling people assholes.
But then there's senior editor,
a senior writer who travels
and covers news on the ground.
Why but put.
Hold on.
Isn't that funny or isn't it interesting?
I mean it's just some shitty recipes.
like the only thing that's odd about it
is that it's a gab shitty recipe because
it was just a shitty recipe online.
But that's my question.
Say it was on medium,
which by the way,
we can't leave without
talking about Jeff Bezos.
Alright,
well we can get into that.
Let's,
let's talk about it.
But if it was on medium,
if someone said like,
look at these dummies with
their terrible fucking recipes,
it would still be almost as interesting,
but it's flavored by.
You're allowed to mock
them because it's your job.
But.
But it's,
it's almost like they're uneducated.
You know,
vox ran an article claiming that people
who hold alt right views are like 11
million or some huge number
and that's just like,
it's absurd.
That's not 11 million american.
What you defined outright as being
some sort of a white supremacist.
I will quote the associated.
Okay.
Associated press.
The aap guidelines are that alt
right means white nationalist,
a designer.
Can I ask you this?
Who defined that?
How does it,
why are they.
Because Richard Spencer is the
man who popularized the term.
Yeah.
So he's not the one who coined it,
but he popularized it and
he is a white nationalist.
Right.
So,
I Mean,
you know,
if you want to be a part of his movement,
there are certain things that
are attached to it and uh,
other,
other people have written
huge things about what it is.
So the ap said,
these are our guidelines and I'll,
I'll defer to the associated press.
I have a lot of respect for them.
There you go.
You know,
so if,
if there's a news organizations,
there was a willamette weekly,
this is god man.
I just really,
I,
I worked for vice,
I was actually a one.
I'm one of the key reasons vice news
exists and I look back on it now.
It makes me kind of sad how
they've written some of these,
most of these ridiculous articles.
I'm really proud of a lot
of stuff they've done,
but I,
I quit.
I quiT when I got an offer from
fusion and fusion is an abc,
univision joint venture.
When I,
when I started there,
they said we won't be
partisan for some reason.
They decided to go far left and start
pushing a lot of things that I thought
were wrong.
They,
uh,
told me to in effect lie right.
So the,
the thing I'll bring up is I
just have such disdain for these,
these news organizations and how they
use definitions that suit their needs to
get the clicks they want
your ultra right today.
You're not outright.
Tomorrow's fine,
right?
The,
the,
the click thing isn't an issue,
right?
Um,
how much of an issue is that journalists
are essentially fighting for their
lives because newspaper is almost dead.
It's online.
Publications are trying.
They're trying to get subscriptions.
Like I subscribe to several different
news online publication that used to be
newspapers,
but the last time I picked
up an actual newspaper,
it's so much so that I felt like I had
a joke about reading something in the
paper and uh,
like turning the pages.
I almost felt like I'm a liar for doing
a joke about turning the page of a
paper.
Right.
I don't remember the last
time I fucking did that.
Everything I've read is either
on a tablet or on a laptop or
do you know,
do you know what the
galman amnesia effect is?
No.
When you're an expert in mma,
you're like one of the foremoSt experts.
Have you ever read a news article
about mma that was so wrong?
Okay,
so that same newspaper,
you're reading it,
you see that store and you laugh how
ron it could be you turn the page and
there's a story about Syria and you go,
I didn't know that.
Why would you forget how wrong they were?
But the reason I bring this up is the
analogy is that you turn the page.
Nobody does.
You click the link.
Right?
Right.
But,
uh,
but let's talk about clicks.
One of the things we talked about
the other day is traffic assignment.
So I know you asked me this.
They're fighting for their lives.
It's a serious issue,
but I just like to point out their
lives never existed in the media space.
Yeah,
please explain that because that was one
of the most illuminating aspects of our
conversation on the phone.
yeah.
Um,
it's,
it's publicly known but not talked
about a whole lot that these media
organizations,
mostly these digital new startups
don't actually get a lot of views.
So what they do is it's
called a traffic assignment.
There's a company called comscore
that tracks the viewership.
The unique views these sites have.
If you're trying to attract investment
and you say we get 20 million views per
month,
they're going to say,
that's cool,
but this site get 60.
What do they do?
Well,
there are some sites.
This is according to variety.
Modern farmer.com.
What is that?
I have,
I have no idea.
I've never heard of it,
but there are many sites which you've
probably seen where it's like the top 25
celebrities who you know,
mess up their makeup.
Yes.
You click the page and I'll show you a
photo in order to see the next photo.
You got to click the next page.
That's that way.
They turn you one person to
25 unique views are 25 years.
I don't wanna say unique.
Then accompany like vice for instance,
we'll buy the assignment of your
traffic and attribute it to themselves.
So when the comscore numbers come out it
will say all of those views from those
clickbaits sites are actually vice.
Right.
That's fucking crazy.
And so there was a controversy a bit.
Again,
I'm quoting variety here.
I don't want to get sued,
but variety said that their traffic went
down 17 percent because someone they
were buying traffic assignment from was
like going through turmoil and shake and
being shaken,
shaken up and another one of their
traffic assignment partners switched to I
think like,
you know,
got sold to nbc or something.
So.
So what ends up happening?
Well,
I can say I'm a little bit.
There was a company that was a
prominent digital news outlet.
I knew someone there who was a decently
high up who told me our company is
contemplating whether or not we should
engage in traffic assignments to inflate
our numbers.
And I said,
don't do it like,
that's wrong.
And they said,
but we need investment.
So I wonder if is that fraud?
yes.
But if comscore is,
is just lumping the numbers
together and I go to you and say,
according to comscore,
our network brings in 60 million.
I didn't lie.
That's all true.
Yes,
that's true.
So here's what happens.
These companies get massive investment.
They don't actually generate
enough clicks or enough money.
Then once the investment runs out,
those jobs never existed.
Those were,
those were padded by investors.
So god,
that's squirrely.
Everything collapses.
It seems like fraud.
I mean,
it does to me.
Yeah.
That seems like if that was,
if you were doing that with,
uh,
some tech stock.
Yup.
Yeah.
Right?
Yup.
Musically or something like that,
you know,
uh,
I was told by another individual who was
at one of these digital companies that
he felt like what we were seeing was
akin to the securities a problem,
the mortgage back securities
from designate that,
if that's a better analogy.
Right?
That's what he said.
He said,
think about this.
You've had all of these big companies,
these big investment,
hundreds of millions of dollars,
$200,000,000 invested into these digital
media outlets because they're seeing
these numbers,
but underneath there's
nothing there and it's crazy.
So if you're investing money,
so if you've got some,
some cash,
you've worked your ass off and you've
generated a lot of money and you're like,
look,
we're going to get into the digital space.
We have a website that has 90 million
clicks and we're going to take that,
and then you find out you
just got fucking host.
How has that not fraud?
Because buyer beware.
Well,
because there's laws that legalized fraud.
You know?
Here's the thing,
right?
I use a lot.
Is it a law?
But it's.
It's,
it's,
it's an interesting loophole.
It's not fraud because
they didn't lie to you,
they didn't deceive you.
You had every opportunity to look at those
numbers and see where they came from,
to understand what their network was.
Okay,
well that may be the case,
but the act of doing it,
the act of the fact that
you can do it and it really,
you're getting monitoring.
It's fucking crazy shady,
but I'll tell you,
I'll tell you what,
I'll something else too,
and I,
and I say this with
the utmost respect for,
for shane smith who,
um,
you know,
I worked at vice,
we've gone out for drinks.
They flew me.
I love shane.
He's cool dude,
but he's brilliant.
Absolutely brilliant.
He is,
he is a master of a,
I don't know what you would call it,
but it's a form,
you know,
so I,
I grew up with a bunch of hacker buddies
and in a small little hacker community
and social engineering is something that
I've been relatively well versed in and
shane,
whether he knows it or not really really
understands how people think and how to
get them to do things.
So I'll give you a,
a fascinating example.
I left a vice in 2014 and after I left,
some of the people I had had brought on
through recommendation were still there.
This buddy of mine says,
dude,
good news.
I'm going to be running the,
I'm going to be helping produce the
news program for the cable channel.
I was like,
wow,
congratulations.
Does that mean you're moving to toronto?
He goes,
why would I move to toronto and I was
like to work on the cable channel.
This is back in 2014.
He goes,
we were talking about we're
getting a cable channel.
I'm going to work on the new show,
and I was like,
dude,
it was a rogers deal.
The cable channels in Canada.
It wasn't a couple years later,
so they got the us based channel,
but what happened was a bunch of my
friends who worked at vice didn't know the
cable channel they got
was based in Canada,
but they believed they were going to be
working on a cable channel in the us.
that's important because you need people
to really want to work there and be
passionate and shane was a master of
giving you just enough information so that
you believed in what you were doing
without realizing it's actually not that
great and I've got.
I'm not trying to be dick.
I think shane's fantastic.
I don't blame him for this,
but it's clever.
You get a bunch of employees who believe
they are going to be on this big new
american cable channel.
Well,
shane never said american.
He just said cable channel.
It's your fault for assuming
it was going to be in America,
but that meant a lot to those employees.
So you're able to boost the morale,
get everybody really excited until
they find out it was in Canada.
And then they were like,
wait,
what?
What?
Eventually they did get their us channel,
but that's shane's.
Uh,
he's brilliant.
He really is.
He's a,
he's a,
you ever play civilization?
The video game?
No,
it's fantastic.
I love this game.
I'm playing civ six right
now and you can get.
They're called great people.
They're called great people,
uh,
that if you earn enough points,
you'll get,
you'll get like galileo,
he'll appear in your civilization museum.
I firmly believe that in 100 years,
the next civilization 50,
you'll be able to earn a great merchant,
shane smith because of how I.
I know he was able to build this empire.
He did it through very clever
ways of getting investment.
And admittedly I really liked the
stuff they used to do back in the day.
I think the guys,
wow,
he,
he knows how to do it and the reason I
bring him up is because the big story
about traffic assignment was vice
losing like 17 percent because of that
practice they were doing.
So he really knew how to
do the smoke and mirrors.
You know what,
when you look at the other,
when you look at how it pays out,
pans out to all the other news outlets,
then having gets laid off,
you have to one,
you don't have to wonder why a thousand
jobs just got lost in the past week.
It was just investment money.
And once they reached their threshold,
it all came crashing down.
God,
the,
the modern farmer example,
like modern farmer,
what is it?
I think with just the clicks,
just the,
the,
the fact that you can actually buy those
clicks anD attribute them to something
different.
And then you can tell people
in the oil will come in.
And he was like,
yeah,
I'll do that.
And send them over to joe rogan.com.
He.
Oh yeah,
and as those other really
clever things to like,
um,
I don't think this one is on par,
but make you have one youtube
channel with a thousand subs,
make 10 more,
ask all your subs and subscribe.
Now you've got 10,000 subs,
get it wrong.
Same thousand people 10
times and you've got,
you go around telling people I've got
10,000 subscribers when in reality it's
just a thousand people on 10 channels.
So it was really clever ways to
inflate your numbers and this attraCts
investment.
It'll,
it also,
but more importantly,
it allows leverage in dealing with
ads with ad buyers and ad networks.
What are people doing when they're
boosting up their instagram numbers?
Uh,
I don't know a lot about instagram.
Kind of pull it up.
I can't show you her and I just
went to a website by youtube.
Use.com for $2,800.
You can have a million views and that's,
but there's,
there's,
um,
there's good reasons to do it.
Not if you want to be a youtuber,
if you want to be successful on youtube,
buying views ensures
you will never make it,
but look at it this way.
No one do this.
No one.
I am not advocating for
one about to explain film.
10 videos,
a full season of the joe rogan travel
adventure by a million views on each to be
pat it out over a month.
Go to a and e.
Look at this show.
We launched million views per episode.
You want to buy it?
Wow.
Got a bunch of fans,
a million people watch youtube episodes.
Fantastic.
You've seen it.
You see what I mean?
Yes.
Well if you're full of shit,
but hey man,
there are people who it's snake
oil is people who do this,
but here's the thing.
You get access to a
network with real views.
You'll get traffic.
You know,
if you can trick your
way into getting on tv,
fake it till you make it.
It's dirty.
It's illegal,
right?
I was illegal.
that's fraud.
Well actually I don't know if that.
I don't think it is fraud if.
Well,
I'm the clicks like that.
I think,
I think New York,
there was someone sent me an article that
the attorney general of one state may
have been New York said,
misrepresenting yourself
online through fake views,
clicks and likes is illegal.
I think what they were saying is that
using Other people's images to create fake
accounts is like invasion
of privacy or something,
but we're getting to that point.
But you know,
there's people who play that game.
I guess you can really.
You can really pull it off.
I've met a lot of people who.
There's a bunch of tricks,
man.
You ever.
You know what team follow
back is from twitter.
you could have seen the hashtag.
What does that mean?
It may have changed,
but essentially I follow
you follow me that way.
You'll see some people have,
they'll be following 100,000 people
and there'll be followed by a hunt,
you know,
90,000 people and then they walk
around bragging about how he got 90,000
followers and it's like,
well hold on.
Like you just have an agreement with them.
You're not influential.
It was a trick that people would
do to inflate their numbers,
but those numbers are legitimate.
If you do post something on twitter,
it will reach 90,000.
Absolutely.
So there's definitely merit in.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It,
it,
I,
I've seen it work.
I've seen it translate,
but it's just a,
it's a,
it's a trick.
It's a trick of getting the system.
Yeah,
there's a lot of sneakiness going on,
but.
Well,
I have fake twitter followers.
I didn't pay for them,
but I've found them through one of those.
How many of your twitter
followers are fake?
Those,
those aren't so good.
Yeah.
What,
what does that mean?
Is it like.
So many of the people don't engage?
I think that's what it's based on.
Right?
And that doesn't make sense.
Well,
it doesn't make sense also because
what if they just are logged in?
They just read.
Exactly.
And that's most twitter users,
right?
Which is still engaging.
You're just not going two ways.
So that's one of the big problems with
tracking fake accounts is that it's just
someone's opinion.
They're most hot.
So there's two things.
Most high profile accounts will read is
having a ton of fake followers because
people will sign up just to follow you
and read what you have to say because
they want your feet.
They want do they want joe,
they want,
you know,
bill clinton or whoever and they
wouldn't have that feed of people.
They don't,
they don't interact and so
then they're labeled fake.
The other thing is when
people make fake bot farms,
they purposefully will follow
people like you so they look real.
So you do get fake ones.
Sure.
And it's hard to know,
you know,
people point to politicians and always
like to claim their fake followers,
but I'll tell you what,
you could.
You could easily go online and
buy followers for someone else.
It happened.
I believe this happened to the daily dot.
I say I believe alex,
I don't wanna get sued just so you know,
the daily.one day jump like 30,000
twitter followers and had to put out a
message saying someone
bought followers for us.
We didn't do thiS.
We are actively trying
to remove them right now.
It's difficult because you don't know
who's real and who's fake after it
happens.
Man.
There's,
there's tears.
You possIbly remove them though.
You'd have to find out what the timeline
was and how quickly they came in and go
to each individual account.
Yeah.
Well there's,
there's a thing that I think there's an
app that allows you to purge what they
view as fake.
You can block and unblock them and
they're not following it anymore.
But it's tough,
man.
They're,
they're,
they're terrifying ways to,
uh,
you know,
I mentioned buying views will
destroy your youtube channel
because youtube knows their fake,
right?
Yeah.
So think about what you can do to
other people if you have three grand,
do you want to damage
by their youtube vibe,
by views for them attributed to
them and get them in trouble.
But I will say for people like you and um,
to an extent,
people like me because I have contacts
at google that wouldn't work on us.
I just make a phone call and say,
I just wanted you to know and they go up,
no problem.
But let's say you're somebody
with 100,000 subscribers,
you know,
you're making a living,
you've got a career on youtube,
but you don't have a manager with youtube,
you don't have contacts with google.
If someone attacks your account,
you're out,
you know,
they,
they can just do that.
Scary.
Yeah.
Yeah,
man.
Jeff bezos.
Oh yeah.
Jeff bezos,
man.
Crazy is the national inquirer.
Allegedly we should say,
allegedly,
I believe allegedly,
I don't want to get sued.
Tried to extort him.
And it's about the jamal [inaudible]
shogi investigation from the Washington
post.
it's all connected to that.
I read,
I read a bit about it.
Um,
I started reading more when ronan farrow
came out and claimed that they went to
him too.
so I'm not as versed like I haven't read.
I read through the day they,
meaning the inquiry.
The inquiry.
Yeah.
Ronan farrow.
um,
it was a store,
I think it was from the
week where I run in.
Pharaoh says that they approached him and,
and you know,
put pressure on him as well.
But,
you know,
the interesting thing is
when I read that story,
I kind of laughed because I was like,
remember gawker member when they public,
when they outdid peter teal,
and then yes,
you know,
a hulk hogan,
like,
you know,
these people are really brave to go up
against billionaires like this and try
and drag them.
Yeah,
I'll also point out it's kind of scary.
You live in a world where a billionaire
can destroy your company because they're
angry at you.
But my,
it's also kind of scary that they can use
this to extort him so that he doesn't,
he takes the Washington post or attempting
to get them to take the Washington
post and remove a legitimate news
story about an actual murder.
I don't trust the Washington post,
but you know,
that's an aside.
That Is like,
if you get it,
you know,
when I look at what the
national enquirer did,
it just reminds me of what the media does.
They know what they can do
and they know how to do it.
The media is influenced its power.
You know,
uh,
brands,
they're scared,
they're scared.
So you look at what happens with some
of these twitter accounts that will lead
campaigns where they encourage all
their followers to send emails.
It's,
it's,
it's not the same as
black male by no means,
but when you know
there's an attack factor,
like,
you know,
what does that wild sardines company,
they don't want to deal with
a brigade from activists.
You tweeted them your fence with them
and they immediately cancel on your show
and they disvalue unless you do something,
unless you say something,
unless you disavow something,
you know.
So granted,
It's leaps and bounds worse when,
when,
when the national inquirer allegedly,
you know,
tries to extort Jeff Bezos.
The craziest thing about it is allegedly,
again,
allegedly that the investigator,
I think his name is becker,
was entertaining the possibility that a
government entity intercepted the texts,
the nude selfies from those.
But I did see another journalist
tweet that they're not entertaining,
that they're not pursuing it.
It was just a thought.
So maybe it's not real.
Well,
part of the thought was that
his girlfriend's brother,
who a trump supporter might
might've somehow or another got
screen grabs of her phone.
It was really interesting when bezos said,
because he owns the post people per
people presume he's their enemy and that's
it.
That's another point I would bring up
to when it comes to like banning Alex
Jones,
just because someone's reporting something
doesn't mean they're advocating for
it,
but sometimes they are.
It's like you've got to
understand the nuance in that.
Yeah.
But yeah,
I mean bezos is probably not
the person you'd want to target.
I could you imagine what would happen if
bayzos showed up at the Washington post
and said,
guys killed the story.
Every journalist would tweet it based.
I'll shut up and just killed our story.
Yeah.
It's almost impossible.
So,
so unrealistic,
but maybe there's more to it.
I mean,
yeah,
the,
the real,
and this is the big
conspiracy theory was that,
you know,
trump always calls him jeff bozo.
Right,
right,
right.
Someone from that side
is involved in this.
Yeah.
And you know,
because trump's always had this
relationship with the inquirer.
Big concern.
Yeah.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
so I don't,
I don't know.
I guess I,
you know,
this is relatively new story and I've
been here so I don't know as much about it
as I probably should,
which just shows you how crazy digital
media is it digital things like sending
things through the air and it's just
that people can get intercepted.
That's whY,
you know,
when I,
when I mentioned earlier
the potential for civil war,
like we don't know what
it could look like.
This could be it,
it could be special
interests using information.
It's the infOrmation war,
you know,
things that people have talked about.
I was thinking about this a while ago.
It's like,
man,
why?
Why did people shoot
each other 100 years ago?
I mean still do,
but like,
you know,
world war ii,
why are they running it?
Because they wanted to gain control.
They wanted,
they wanted to centralize power or
they wanted to push an ideology or a
government or expand their power.
You don't need to shoot
somebody to do that.
You just need to convince them you're
right or you need to get them to fight
each other.
So I think it's fair to say,
yeah,
the russians are absolutely
screwing with us,
but we've learned through if you trust
the reporting and it's hard to know
what's real or not that
the russian campaigns,
we're not only promoting trump supporters,
but they were promoting
black lives matter.
Why gIve him to fight?
Well,
they weren't just doing that.
There's a fantastic podcast that sam
harris released recently with a woman.
Let me,
let me get her name so I can
see if you can find a jamie.
It's called the information war.
That's the name of the podcast.
But uh,
they were,
they were doIng all sorts
of different things,
like not just trying to.
Rene de arrest,
teresita and I'm working on getting
her down here soon that they were.
They also had like a Texas culture.
They had trans rights.
They have,
they,
they even organize facebook campaigns
where they had a pro Texas group and a pro
muslim group meet across
the street from each other.
Yeah,
I mean they're,
they're sowing seeds of descent,
like organizing it and I think I,
I'd be willing to entertain
the possibility that what
we call the culture war
today was seated specifically
by special interests,
potentially Russia.
Nothing we can do about it.
It's done.
You know,
when,
when people adopt an ideology,
you can easily that and some people
refuse to cross that divide,
you know?
Yeah.
But it's just so funny how many
different ways they were attacking this.
They had a blue lives matter groups,
black lives matter groups,
and they put people at odds with each
other and one of the big ones that they
did was they,
they targeted african americans and we're
trying to get them to vote for anyone
other than hillary.
And this is like an engineered campaign
that jill stein's our vote and we like,
we can't vote for hillary.
Like hillary does not support us.
We can't vote for hillary.
And so it made it very tribal.
The first thing we have,
we have to assume is that it was effective
and what we view in the culture war
was exacerbated by these campaigns.
We don't know,
we don't know to what extent they
had an influence over the us,
but I will say I think it's fair to point
out they play a role and then we can
see what happens.
Charlottesville,
you know,
where we can see the dramatic escalation
where you end up with some crazy guy
associated with white nationalism
ramming a car into a bunch of protesters.
It's,
you know,
people get riled up to a point as a
really great video called this video will
make you angry by,
um,
cgp grey where he talks
about how these groups,
they argue amongst each other,
not against each other.
They make each other angry By
posting images of the other,
you know,
there's certain subreddits.
Why I don't want to start a brigade,
but they'll post memes nonstop
attacking a particular politician.
They're not arguing with
the left or the right.
They're arguing to themselves
about what's wrong with the other.
And so these groups grow
and get angrier and angrier.
And then when they finally
meet in the real world,
you get extreme violence.
So it's very,
it's very possible to seed those
communities and rile people up,
push these things.
Yeah.
well it's also,
it seems pretty straightforward how to
manipulate them and how to appeal to
their tribal nature and it's
terrifying how easy it is.
Yeah man.
But you know,
the store is so terrifying
how few people are aware that,
I mean there's a lot of these really
toxic pages that you'll find that they're
commenting on things that are,
whether it's instagram or
twitter or whatever they're not,
they're not really who you think they are
and what ends up happening.
The average person say on twitter,
we'll look at their mentions and
see 10 tweets where they say,
you shouldn't talk about this anymore.
How dare you.
And they'll assume everyone when
in reality could be one person,
but it works well.
And this is,
this is what gets companies to run
away from sponsoring shows and stuff.
They think everyone's attacking them.
It could be one person.
Where do you think this goes?
If you're,
if you're looking aT this
like this is fairly new,
right?
all of this stuff is fairly
new and and really kind of a,
this is uncharted territory in terms of
how to navigate this stuff and they're
sort of figuring out what the
influences are as we go along.
And again,
10 years ago this didn't even exist.
So this is all all new.
Where do you think it's going?
Usd.
Stabilization,
real and edit.
Dangerous.
Dangerous level.
So patrion,
right?
It's the,
it's the independent economy.
If you're a youtuber,
if you're a podcaster,
if you're an,
if you're a cost play or whatever.
Well they decided to band Some people
for reasons that don't make sense.
Like sargon didn't violate the tos,
but they banned in many ways.
So sargon goes to subscribe.
Star activists then decide sargon and
shouldn't be allowed to make money,
period.
So they start,
you know,
campaigning unsubscribed,
star,
subscribes to our loses,
access to paypal and stripe so it
can no longer process payments.
Who made that decision to remove it?
Most likely pay pal,
I believe.
I believe they sent on the website.
Paypal,
you know,
because what happens is people get scared,
oh,
we don't want to be involved in this.
While something else happened,
subscribes are reactivated there.
They've got new payment processor,
which means we've seen
the budding off of an,
of a,
of a mirror economy,
which is dangerous.
The fact that americanS in general
can't share the same platform and had to
create an alternate,
an alternate that had to be
supported by separate means.
If this continues in that direction,
we're going to end up with tons of
systems that operate for only certain
political factions.
jack,
uh,
jack conte,
the page,
the ceo of patriot said to I believe cnbc.
You can't say anything
you want in the world.
What does what I say in the
world had to do with what you,
what service you provide.
Now,
by all means,
if you want to bend them,
you can,
but you can then see the
adopting of ideology.
Someone posted a funny comment accompany
that refuses to sell water to a
dehydrated man in the desert
because they think the wrong thing.
But then what happens?
Different companies emerge and you'd
get tribes that are divided not only by
their ideology,
but literally they're unable
to communicate with each other.
That can only lead to one thing.
The tribes getting physical,
charlottesville,
portland ball to a.
I'm a boston berkeley,
san bernardino.
These various instances where the.
They've claShed and bashed each other.
People have been killed.
Some people show up with guns.
I think that's.
I don't I,
I've got to be honest.
I don't think there's a way to fix it.
I don't really.
There is a,
a hilarious comment.
I'm sorry.
Comic programmer humor on reddit and
they said when you talk to an airplane
engineer or mechanic,
they say,
oh yeah,
these things are engineered safety.
You're,
you're more likely to get new car
accident and died in an airplane.
You know,
when you talk to electrical engineers,
oh god,
we've got so many redundancies
that the system will fail.
If you know,
when you talk to a programmer,
everything's,
everything's bad.
Voting machines or corrupt,
the system is failing.
We can't secure it.
like there was a kid at
defcon hacker convention who.
Active voting machine like that,
like the whole system is.
I got to say,
you know that story I
told you about high times,
imagine if someone did that,
but it was a political story in how
easy would it be to rile people up and
getting violent.
It's,
it's,
it's dangerously easy.
It's terrifying.
It's very easy to get people
riled up with fig stories and,
and you know,
and once they go viral
there's no stopping it.
And I think we're seeing a really even
more terrifying phenomenon in that even
when we have evidence
in front of our eyes,
covington,
people refuse.
Reza aslan for instance,
he won't back down.
It's like the,
the,
it was the first video that just shows
the one kid standing next to philips that
goes viral.
I can understand why people
saw that and were like,
whoa.
But the second video that went viral,
almost the exact same time showed
phillips walk up to the kid immediately
disproving the original narrative
of the kid approached him.
but even bill maher still got it wrong.
You know?
So even when people can
see exactly what happened,
it doesn't fit their narrative,
don't believe it.
And,
and there was an article that I think it
may have been in gizmodo or deadspin or
something that said,
don't listen to them.
We all know what we saw and it's like,
dude,
that's if we're getting to the point where
kids at a blackout basketball game we
have aren't black body paint
and throwing up three pointers.
Signs is nazis.
How do you,
how do you bring those
people back from that,
from the brink?
And,
and I'll say this too,
like I obviously have been,
you know,
I've,
uh,
didn't mention alt right
violence all that often.
But then you have to realize
the alt right is tiny,
tiny,
tiny.
They're,
they're rare.
They've admitted defeat.
You know,
Richard Spencer said,
I think he said this at
antifa one or something.
No one showed up.
He had an event in Florida.
11 people shut up.
I'm not worried about that guY.
I'm worried about these fringe
ideologies that are racist,
intolerant and violent.
Slowly seeping into our culture.
Like when you see a politician's openly
embrace like race based government
policy,
it's really does worry me,
you know,
my I,
I think I have this perspective growing
up in a mixed race family where I've
been insulted by the left for being
white and I've been insulted by far right
racists for being and so
I don't like either of it.
I reallY don't,
but the white supremacists types are
falling apart and they don't threaten me
anymore.
They,
they,
they just don't,
but the left wing racism and the
and these ideas of racial equity and
determining what your worth based on
the color of your skin are becoming more
and more pervasive.
the lawsuit with harvard that,
that asians have a harder standard,
a tougher standard for getting in even
though agents or a smaller minority than
white people.
Why does that make sense?
why should I have to approach
someone and justIfy my race to them?
That terrifies me.
It really does,
and we will.
We see kirsten gillibrand tweet
the future as intersectional.
Intersectionality is that
ideology of race based polIcy.
[inaudible] has put forth,
puts,
puts forth the green new
deal that says racial equity.
I,
I prefer to judge someone on
the content of their character,
not the color of their skin.
Well,
it's also,
that's the kind of talk
that gets trump reluctant.
Oh god.
And that's that one.
That's one of my biggest
pet peeves because,
you know,
I've talked about progressive tax.
I think we can do a lot for a public
option for expanding medicaid.
Uh,
the,
the idea of a green new deal at
its core to me is fascinating.
Can,
can the government,
you know,
can we allocate tax money to
invest in new technologies,
fusion nuclear and reduce carbon
emissions and do great things.
Can we make high speed rails?
But then when you come out and say,
pay the unwilling and these other
equity things in intersectionality,
I'm like,
that's not,
that's not what I'm talking about.
I can't support that.
The unwilling is the
most preposterous one.
The idea that someone's unwilling to
work and we need to provide them with a
living.
That's insanity.
I mean,
that's the ultimate progressive bend,
but in that's where it keeps going,
but where they're trying to out
progressive the next concept,
but,
but hold on in a socialist or
communist society stuff to work.
Yeah.
I don't know what society exists where
you expect people to undertake the
greatest construction project
in the history of humanity,
a massive train network that
makes all planes obsolete,
but at the same time tell people they
don't have to work if they want money.
Well,
this is what we're saying is like,
as these ideologies get
more and more ridiculous,
they try to out progressive the next step,
like it's a fundamental right
for you to earn a living.
And,
and pew pew research recently
put out a poll last week,
couple weeks ago,
democrat,
the democratic party,
54 percent want more moderate policies.
So I'm,
I fall in that bracket,
but still,
you still have about 43 or so that
want more left leaning policies.
But what that means is the party split.
And so here,
here's the problem.
I see.
If you're going to put me up,
if you're gonna,
say,
tim,
you got to vote,
you have to vote,
you have to make a choice.
You've got a moderate conservative who
believes things I really don't agree
with,
but he doesn't want to give money to
people that don't work and he doesn't
believe in identitarian politics
and race equity or whatever.
And then you've got the democrats
who are so far left to me,
I can't even see them anymore.
Who do you think,
you know,
a social liberals and liberals are gonna
vote for the closest person to them
politically will be a conservative.
You know,
that's what scares me.
we had this great future with a potential
for a public option for expanding
medicaid for.
I mean,
look,
I,
I really do believe social
programs are important.
We can do more.
I like a lot of what bernie has to say.
I think we need to reform education,
but I think education could be expanded.
Again,
I'm interested in the ideas.
I want to advocate for them,
but we need to figure out how to do it.
But my po,
like where I fit politically,
I'm politically homeless.
I don't agree with someone
judging me based on my race.
I've been through that.
Hell no.
Never again.
People vandalizing my home because they
didn't like that at a brown mom and a
white dad.
I don't want to live in that world.
I don't want you to look
me in the eyes and say,
I tell people,
look at this way.
When it comes to harvard,
I want you to look into the eyes
of that little asian boy and say,
honey,
you can't go to harvard.
You're asian.
You look too much like those people.
How does that make sense?
Why is it that just because this
kid looks similar to this kid,
you're going to tell him he
has a harder standard for pat,
for the sats to get into the school.
I just,
I,
I refuse.
I absolutely do.
It's disgusting.
And the fact that it's coming from
harvard is so confusing that the high.
I mean that is the school,
right?
When,
when you think about higher learning,
where'd you grow up?
Where my dad graduated from harvard.
Well,
harvard,
harvard.
That's the school and the fact
that they're practicing this way,
they say it's because
if they didn't do that,
the student body would
be overwhelmingly asian,
disproportionate to the
ketchup white people.
I don't care.
I,
I don't think you get to look at
someone and say you look too much.
Like they do know.
It's crazy.
It's,
it's not a meritocracy.
If you do that,
um,
I want to talk to you about
the universal basic income.
What do you think about,
what do you think about
artificial intelligence and
automation and the removal of all these
jobs is a real concern that a lot of
people have.
And then the way to mitigate it that's
being bandied about is universal basic
income that they would give you a certain
amount of money and I think the idea
is that everyone would get it.
Even wealthy people would get it.
Yeah.
And that would be the
only way to make it fair,
but where the fuck is
that money coming from?
And then what do you think about it?
I don't think.
I'm not an economiSt man,
but I don't.
I don't think it's feasible,
at least right now,
I do believe that on a technological
level we will eventually reach like a star
trek kind of future where
it's not about communism,
it's just literally like we
have no scarcity is gone.
Like they have replicators,
but when it comes to
universal basic income,
people need to understand some
basic economic principles.
If everybody gets a thousand dollars,
okay,
that's $300,
million thousand dollars.
Right?
Right.
But it's not everybody.
It's everybody of working age,
right?
Yes.
So,
so let's,
let's,
let's do this.
I own a,
I own a burger shop.
I need to hire someone to flip burgers.
So I say we pay 10 bucks an hour.
It's a,
it's not,
it's not a lot,
but we're a small business.
We can't really afford to pay more.
Is that acceptable?
They say I get a thousand bucks a month.
Why would I,
why would I spend,
you know,
if,
if you know that not really well the is
that the thousand bucks a month that you
get,
you get to keep and then the time
is worth more than 10 bucks an hour.
I don't care what,
when I,
when I was 17,
18,
I worked for american eagle airlines.
I was lifting like 50,000 pounds per day
and I was getting 10 bucks an hour and
in jacked.
No,
I was.
I've been skateboarding my whole life,
so I was certainly,
you know,
in shape.
But if you gave,
if you told me,
hey,
you know how you're making less than a
thousand bucks a month working fulltime
after taxes,
how about we just give
you a thousand bucks?
I bet I'll be the skatepark yeah,
I'll,
you know.
So there's some positives that
people will pursue their passions,
but hold on.
How many people do you
know want to be comedians?
And they're not funny.
A few.
Quite a few.
And imagine if you said we're going to
subsidize your endeavor into a thing.
You're not good at how many People
are really good at being carpenters,
but they wished they'd
be pro football players.
How many people are really good at being
teachers but want to be a famous actor?
So what do you think would be some sort
of an appropriate response to automation
and artificial intelligence?
I mean,
you can't just have millions and
millions of people just have nowhere to,
you know.
And that's,
that's a,
a technical,
let's say.
This is why I uh,
you know,
I've,
I've never been a pot sMoker.
I,
I smoked like once in my life.
I want to try.
No,
no,
it's just not my thing,
but everyone always would think I was
stoned because I would talk about this
kind of stuff with my friends
while they were stoned.
The philosophical consequences
of technological innovation.
It is not the postMaster's fault that he
spent 30 years becoming the best of the
best in working at the post office.
That technology emerged that is going
to displace him and make him put them in
the poor house.
Right.
When I was about 19 years old,
I was skateboarding in downtown chicago
and I saw an old black homeless man and
I had some leftover food and I was like,
hey,
what's up dude?
You want some food?
And he was like,
oh thanks man.
And I was just like,
I got to know,
can I ask you a question?
how did you become homeless?
And he said,
uh,
you know,
it man,
he's,
I think he was like 60 something.
He said I used to have a job.
Uh,
I worked all day day.
I had a family.
Uh,
eventually,
you know,
um,
my,
uh,
didn't have kids.
My friends started
getting old and move on.
I lost touch with a lot of them.
Some of them died and one day I got told
that my job wasn't needed anymore and
so I could know anything.
Went on unemployment for a little bit.
But my,
you know,
the job I was good at,
it didn't exist.
Right.
I can't remember exactly what he said.
There's this 14 years ago,
but he was like,
so everywhere I went,
I said,
I'll do anything,
I'll do anything.
But even the small jobs that paid a little
bit to flip burgers weren't enough to
cover mY rent.
After a few months I got evicted then
because I didn't have a place to live,
I couldn't go to the job.
I did have started sleeping outside.
And I've been here ever since.
I'm like,
that said,
you know,
and that's,
that's,
that's a sad reality.
What do you do?
I don't know doc,
but your hooks you up.
But that's the thing.
She goes too far.
But this is why I believe in some
kind of social policy and safety net,
social security,
something to help these people.
Well for sure.
You know,
if we have a real community,
you would help out the people that
are in your community too big.
Yes.
That's the,
you know,
communism works really,
really well when you
have like five people.
Yeah.
I try explaining to people they
always make this political,
the political compass.
Authoritarian lIbertarian left,
right?
And they,
they.
People like to claim that anarchists
like the violent smashy ones,
an antifa are libertarian left.
And I'm like,
no,
no.
Like the libertarian left
quadrant are pot smoking,
hippies live on farms and arco
communism makes a ton of sense.
when it's you and your buddies
working together on a farm sharing
responsibilities.
It doesn't make sense for a community
of 300 million people and you have to
trade extremely specific resources
to make a computer happen.
Right?
At that point,
do you need to be able to quantify
the value of Specific objects?
And that's why communism
doesn't work for massive,
massive scale,
but
I will say when a artificial intelligence,
a different conversation,
you know,
technological advancements,
advancement is going to
result in like luddite riots.
You know,
people,
you know,
the opioid crisis.
I,
I could be wrong.
I read that there was a connection
between unemployment from these factories
getting shut down and
depressed dudes popping pills.
there was a,
a masculinity report was published by
harry's shaving company and they said the
over the overwhelming majority of what
contributes to a man's happiness as
gainful employment,
like,
like 80 percent.
So what happens when a factory shuts down?
You got a bunch of young dudes
who wanted to do something.
they want to matter,
but they can't.
There's no,
there's no where to go anymore,
especially in a small town.
But I'll tell you what,
men percosets feel real good.
you know,
those drugs,
they feel fantastic,
but they'll kill you.
So that's,
you know,
I think this contributes to the
popularity of bernie sanders and trump.
They talked about the working class.
I talked about these
free trade agreements,
hurting people.
they talked about gettIng the factories
back together and that means a lot to
people who have been popping
pills who are depressed,
who are sad and scared and so a
lot of people in this country.
So to wrap this up,
I'm the only.
The only other thing that I think
I would like to at least make
an attempt at is what would be the path
for a person who's been banned from
these social media sites?
What,
what do you think would be a reasonable
way to bring people back into the
conversation,
whether it's youtube or whatever.
What would be a reasonable way mean?
Don't you think?
Just shouldn't be in a bag.
Honest,
reinstate it.
Just anybody,
anybody.
No matter what they've done.
well,
if you commit a crime,
you got to,
you know,
you get caught,
you go to jail,
right?
Then when you get out,
you're free to engage in normal,
you know,
civic behavior.
Do you think that the concept of a
permanent ban is in some way almost an
american concept?
Oh man.
I don't know.
To get that specific,
like while we're into freedom of speech,
what does that mean?
I believe that as long as these companies
are monopolies and they are the public
sphere,
it is wrong to permanently exile someone
for saying a bad word for holding the
wrong opinion will mean a lot of these
like learn to code or they're fucking
preposterous.
I mean to ban someone permanently for
something that well for saying a man is
never a woman.
Right.
That was a permanent ban.
Men aren't women though.
Yes.
That's.
That's absurd and terrifying.
Yeah,
but even.
I'm like milo being banned.
Right?
Why?
Because he was tweeting at a celebrity.
You're supposed to tweet it.
Celebrities only that it was a.
I mean,
the criticism of that movie was no
different than the criticism of any movie
that they thought sucked.
Right.
But it happened to be about
a feminist idea or a woman's.
And what was,
what was interesting is that,
I mean,
it's been so long,
so forgive me if I get this wrong,
but I believe leslie jones was tweeting
her followers to go to my low as well or
something that I believe so.
Well,
you know,
she's,
she's done some,
some questionable tweets herself.
Hey look,
people block me for no reason.
Uh,
I have no idea why some
people have locked me.
Yeah.
I've gone to people's pages and
found that unblocked block lists.
Yeah.
Well,
there's a solution if you don't,
if you don't.
So what they say,
what they say is,
um,
it's actually really
interesting precedent.
The daily stormer encouraged.
This is I'm going off of some
news reports that could be wrong,
encouraged people to send,
you know,
racist images and start sending mean
thanks to this woman who I think,
I believe it was an asian or black and
a court ruled that the first amendment
will not protect you if you encourage
others to engage in harassment.
It's really interesting.
Then when we cOnsider what's going to
happen with the lawsuits towards all of
the people who smeared and defamed and
called for action against the covington
kids,
that precedent that was used against
daily stormer is not going to be used
against these high profile celebrities
and personalities and are there lawsuits
that are being formed right now for that?
Yeah.
The big news,
the five Lawyers,
I think I remember the guys name,
huge list to ethnography.
Use your list a lot of like,
you know,
a lot of people did like their tweets,
but a lot of people didn't retract
like bill maher four days later.
It'S like after people are already
offering to represent these and threatened
lawsuits,
bill maher then comes out
with his bad information,
but anyway,
ultimately to the point of redemption,
we shouldn't permanently exile people for
saying things that we think are wrong.
What really scares me
about the Alex Jones thing.
I'm not.
What I'm about to say is not declined.
the Alex Jones is mentally
deficient or anything like that.
That's not my.
That's not whatever you want.
The point is,
if your justification for banning him
is that he said san diego wasn't real,
does that mean people who are who don't
have a grasp on reality aren't allowed
to use social media?
Is that,
does that mean that people who
are stupid ontologic social media,
people who are mentally ill have to
have an intelligence test to use social
media?
That's insane.
People are allowed to say what they want
to say and I think so long as twitter
is a monopoly,
they should probably.
We should probably have some protections
on the ability to engage in public
discourse.
I'll give you a really imporTant point.
Occupy wall street took place in zucotti
park in New York on what's called a
privately owned public space pops.
This space is owned by a private entity.
However,
they had no legal grounds for evicting
the protesters from the park because it
was encouraged.
The public was encouraged to come,
so I would argue if twitter has actively
encouraging public participation,
they lose the protections
to band whoever they want.
I think it's rather terrifying that
you would seed political power in this
capacity to foreign interests.
Stockholders and private individuals
at a massive corporation,
mr.
Monopoly,
that's not even beholden to the u.
S to a certain degree,
you know,
I forgive me for being a little bit of a
liberal who wants regulation on massive
corporations,
but I'm just,
I,
I'm surprised I don't see it
from other people on the left.
It's a very compelling argument and
I think the more it's fleshed out,
the more it seems to.
we definitely have an issue.
It's a giant issue and it doesn't go
away.
You just banned people.
Oh no.
You create parallel economies,
worlds and you end up with a backlash.
Yeah.
Well listen man.
Um,
I'm really happy you came.
I'm really happy we did
this and just thank you.
Thank you for educating me on this and
giving you a perspective and it's a very,
very articulate and very intelligent
perspective and I really appreciate it.
And I think for everyone this helps
us to sort of get an understanding of,
you know,
this,
the whole spectrum of what's
going on with all this stuff.
Yeah.
And alice add by saying,
I don't think I'm the
smaRtest person in the world.
I probably got a lot.
I probably get a lot wrong.
I do my best to try and
have my facts straight.
If I don't forgive me,
fact,
check me all the time,
you know,
do your due diligence,
but I appreciate your perspective.
Thank you brother.
Thank you,
man.
Thank you.
We'll do this again.
Yeah,
tim,
pull.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Bye.
Cool.
Okay.